in five four three two one hello
everybody welcome to an episode of the
genius brain podcast where we have two
very special guests we have Khalif and
Megan Megan is risky her job while we're
lacking in all serious it's some real
[__] so I think I think people have kind
of seen a trend on this podcast I think
I've allotted about every week or so
we've we've done a topic on this podcast
where it has to do with what's going on
in this country now specifically when it
comes like the BLM topic right I know
there's like momentum that's starting to
fizzle out a little bit I see it
happening you know even though people
said it wasn't going to everybody can
call it it was gonna start to die out a
little bit it always happens so I think
my thing is like whoa let's just talk
about it on the podcast and let's have
it let's have that conversation to
continue specifically and I think I
brought this up recently and this is
just like a small microcosm that's kind
of reflective of what goes on I think in
the school system in general right so we
if you guys have been listening to this
podcast we talked about the school
Whitney which both these people here are
alumni from that school and kind of
what's going on in this school is a
reflection of number one in my personal
opinion about the education system and
how it treats like people of color
topics issues and how to handle these
situations and we just had this
conversation today Natalie just before
we started about how people sometimes
misinterpret um when they say like you
say racist things they go or you're
calling me a racist those things are
very separate very separate very very
separate because you could say
insensitive things and not really know
and I told the story about when we first
met Muriel right I was like can I touch
your hair and I was like hey don't do
that
she didn't understand why she goes I'm
just curious like well cool I'm a random
guy and I got into petting zoo
yeah let me uh let me run my fingers
through your hair how would you feel I
should go oh I could see how that's
weird
but those type of things haven't been
explained to her she's not racist
however it's a very racially insensitive
thing to come up and try to pet them
like they're an animal but you don't see
it that way you know but Lissa let's go
into the topic of what's going on at
Whitney right now because you guys
specifically are trying to change a lot
of the culture there and we talked about
this on the podcast well I was i I asked
a recently about this too right cuz you
guys went out to go drop off the check
for from YBS oh yes and then I brought
it up on the podcast where you know John
was saying oh well I'm glad that when
he's taking initiative I was like but
are they really because when Khalif went
there and he was like here's the chat
for ybs and they go what's why yes
yeah it's like yo what the [__] is going
on but I think that's indicative to the
black experience out Whitney as a whole
and I say that because even in that
situation right like okay it was
mentioned flippantly like oh why BS
doesn't have so much money or they don't
have this much money so they can't bring
somebody to campus to help eradicate the
problem of racism towards black people
on campus yeah so you want the kids to
then provide the resource to solving
their own problems that's neither here
nor there we'll get to that later
yeah but you know it was actually it was
Khalif myself and a few of our other
friends but specifically nicole the
reason why I say Nicole is because
Nicole is the co-chair of the black
Alumni Association at Whitney right but
she's also Whitney graduate and the
people in the office have been working
in the office since I was there in a
seventh-grader so we're talking about
the 90s right so Nicole ghost open up
the door and they're like taking it back
and oh what can we help you with what
are you here for we're coming to drop
off money 2yb is what's ybs and it was
like alarm when we're trying to drop off
money that we donated for students that
attend this school
take this money take the first off take
the money but then to you why don't you
know what young bucks dollars is yeah
they're members of this community and
then it wasn't until afterwards right
when they when some of the office people
saw myself and Khalif and then they
recognized us that the whole attitude
changed and I think that speaks more so
to not just ignoring the black
population
Whitney but then also having two people
who maybe you have personal
relationships with right you if Nicole
was a parent or just somebody off the
street and had no ties to Whitney she
still should be treated with respect
she still should be approached with some
sort of like hospitality but the but
nothing shifted until you saw that cliff
and I were there then it's like oh my
gosh it's been so lot like the whole
attitude changed right it's because I
mean it's because of these phrases that
I've heard a lot you know growing up
it's like oh you're really cool for LA
yeah you're not one of those blah yeah
so just to put it in context you know I
had a you know everybody knows my best
friend is this dude named Cabo
so gobble says it's two he's a he's a
physician he's a doctor he's graduating
today Congrats you son of a [__] he
writes oh you know he's a full-fledged
doctor and so you know people were like
oh well you know you don't have any of
those issues well listen once I leave
this hospital I I'm not in doctor gear
when I'm in the grocery store I'm just a
black man that's it I don't have to tell
people hey I'm an MD treat me with
respect that part I know why does it
have to be that so I think there's a
huge distinction that people just have a
problem recognizing right and it's
getting to the point now where I feel
like it you know these type of
conversations have come up so many times
people think that it's annoying but the
reason why it annoys is because there's
an effect you want to daily eggs it's
not your actual existence yeah you know
to quote the prodigal son prophet Kanye
West even if you're still even if you're
in a bin and I'm gonna say it you're
still a [__] in a coop and that's the
thing is that no matter how much as a
black person we assimilate and you know
bring ourselves up pull ourselves up
from the bootstraps create the American
dream no matter how educated you are no
matter how much money you have or you
give away or you do these charitable
things you are still black in America
yeah which means you are still at the
bottom of the totem that was a hard part
because when we watch that
I'm pretty sure everybody has seen it
now because it's all over the place is
that with that kid Elisha McCain right
and you know you had this young man
worked at Massage Envy on his free time
he played the violin which he taught
himself for foster cats right kids a
really sweet guy you couldn't find
anything about this kid which I'm pretty
sure a lot of people were trying to
research and find the stuff and damage
her that's yeah you know he's walking
down the street he's a weird kid he's a
little bit on the spectrum so he's like
dancing his ass off whatever he just
came from a convenience store cops pull
up to him because somebody in the
neighborhood said there's somebody weird
that's on the street they asked him if
he was dangerous or if he has a weapon
he says no so why are you dear people
let me that's to get your people if
you're not in any immediate threat and
there's no reason for you to be
concerned don't call the police on black
people can we can we just get that like
if I was to call the police on every
word person I saw walking down the
street
black lives we wouldn't have to say
black lives matter because all those
people would be dead or in jail Yeah
right if it was the same reaction like
he has people have a right to be weird
you have a right to be weird there's no
law there is no place in the
Constitution where it says you cannot be
weird and there's always like something
that I'm always waiting for in terms of
what people are gonna write my bagel
well why was he wearing a ski mask
it's [__] Colorado [__] like that's
why he's wearing a [__] ski mask he
was anemic as well too so he gets really
cold and shivers there's a lot of other
reasons but why do we have to keep
having this conversation of like oh the
reason why is because of this this this
isn't this at the end of the day was a
kid dancing in the middle of street
whatever [__] he's weird move on move
on [__] move on what is going to
happen and so if you guys haven't
watched that clip I do want you guys to
watch it in its entirety because
watching sound bites from it is not
enough because there's a big parts that
people were missing from that clip they
go did you hear his last words I'm not
like and it was so sad because he's
literally pleading for his life and the
reason why that should affected me so
hard too is because they kind of
stripped the kids dignity what they did
his dignity because he he
literally had to beg for his [__]
life say I'm a good person
he just started rambling off I don't
even meal didn't care they didn't care
I'm gonna get the dogs on you I'm gonna
taze you if you don't calm down and the
weird part about that whole situation
too was there's a moment in the clip and
I'm not sure if a lot of people picked
this up the cops said a turn off your
body cam yeah switch it off
cuz they knew they were wrong yeah like
this is the thing that is more that is
most infuriating is the fact that your
conscience and I I'm an optimistic
person even being black right I believe
everyone has a conscience mm-hmm at some
point when he said turn off that buck
turn off your camera what his conscience
was telling him to do was to stop mmm
right to say stop doing this but rather
than that you continued don't you
continue listening to the little devil
on your shoulder and killed you murdered
a child like he's not a grown man I
don't care I don't care what you say he
was not of the age of drinking he barely
had the right to vote he's a child yeah
walking home with a ski mask in Colorado
what crime did he commit outside of
being black and also to the paramedic
who shot him up full of ketamine wait
category what was the purpose of that I
think what I was reading to is that I
don't know if like Colorado has a huge
drug problem but that's like their
protocol to get like tweakers to calm
down or some [__] which is [__] weird
to me in the first place like I don't
even know what the [__] is going on
there but you know I've been having a
lot of conversations with trying to get
like active police officers on here and
I understand why they don't want to come
on here but the reason why they don't
want to come on here is the problem that
I'm talking about exactly go well I
can't come on here and I don't want to
say these topics because it's gonna make
me weird and my job in blah blah blah
and you know I might get outed out and
I'm like you're in a gang so just by you
admitting that part it's already
problematic because the the reason why I
wanted to cop on you is just to talk
about what they go through right I want
to know I want if there's no common
ground we can't have a conversation
because if you're telling me that you
can look at that clip and a cop
hey that's protocol right well tell me
what protocol is because I want to hear
it from your mouth right let's talk
about and is anybody trying to change
protocol because that should not be the
norm yeah if that is how police officers
are trained that is not okay and it's
the same way that you know teachers get
more scrutiny for lashing out and
telling a child to like shut the F up
yeah then a cop does for killing
somebody
it's insane it's nuts it is nuts but I
think it speaks to the bigger picture
what you just said is that the the job
of an officers to protect in the serve
in for some way shape or form that
protect and serve has become power and
disenfranchised yeah I'm going to use my
power to make you comply which is then
going to disenfranchise you and strip
you from your dignity it's gonna take
you away from having your voice or being
able to advocate for yourself right
because at some portion of that clip in
the beginning Elijah was advocating for
himself yeah no it's not okay for you
I'm an introvert it's not okay for you
to come into my space yeah it's not okay
for you to touch me or grab me if we can
understand that women shouldn't be
grabbed then why can't we understand
that it's not okay to grab anybody yeah
especially a chat like I think the thing
that I keep trying to drive home is he
was a child and and we were talking
about this earlier were I've had now
conversations with people who have
trained cops and everything else and
obviously you know coming on this
podcast is it's not for everybody but
you know having spoken to them I have
learned that a lot of these cops -
they're not really taught de-escalation
tactic no you know you know like FBI
people right you see somebody you know
who's gonna [__] blow up a building
or jump off a building they're like hey
kid come down from the roof you don't
tell the guy I [__] dare you jump off
right now let's see what happens right
and so that's the type of attitude that
I think a lot of these cops are going in
whether it's because of trauma that
you've had on the force some other stuff
you've seen crazy [__] like a friend of
mine has a friend who's a detective and
he's told me all these crazy stories
he's seen people have their brains blown
out suicide situation
hostage situations that you need therapy
you need therapy and we talked about
this work if we're talking about
defunding the police and people don't
believe in defunding the police because
I think that definition a lot of people
don't know what it means
fine I'm what I'm asking for is an
allocation of your funding to go into
other stuff besides [__] weaponry and
you know aggressive tactics social
services how about that yeah and I think
the thing is is that we always try to
give people the benefit of the doubt I
don't have time to give people the
benefit of the doubt anymore and nor do
I have the patience to do so yeah when
we say defund the police nobody's saying
get rid of the police there those are
two different concepts what we're saying
is maybe you don't need to put millions
and millions and millions of dollars
into military-grade weaponry when you
can invest that money into schools and
social services which has proven to
lower crime rates yeah which then you
wouldn't need all these weapons because
you wouldn't have people out here
committing crimes because they would be
receiving the help and the support that
they need and I wonder - like
definitively what the definition of a
cop is like what what are you like what
are you supposed to do in these
situations are you are you supposed to
go into a situation expect the worst are
you there's really no the peace you know
they are there having family members who
are officers in a really close friend
that is a sheriff their training is for
them to expect the worst yeah it's not
to go in and realize that these are it's
not it's not even to defuse the
situation it's to control the situation
and the difference between defusing and
controlling is control is I am I am
going to get the upper hand in this
situation by any means necessary versus
I am going to try and find a resolve in
a resolution for this and I say this
because you know one of my really close
friends my husband's best friend is an
officer right and it's super interesting
because he actually comes from the
education field he has his he has his
master's degree
in education specifically when it comes
to apply behavioral therapy he worked
with students or he worked with children
that were on the spectrum and that had
other special knees disorders right so
that gives him a completely different
lens when he goes and approaches these
situations but watching his training it
was how to disarm people it was what to
do if somebody pepper sprays you it was
tactical trainee there was nothing in
his training that taught him how to
defuse situations he just knows that
because of his separate educational
background right yeah but so many
officers don't have that extra
background and that really should be
mandatory it really should be and I feel
like as an officer you should want that
you should want that for your personal
mental health and for you to understand
assess these situations because going
back to Elisha McCain if you were a
decent [__] human being and you
understood social situation you probably
would have been able to step back and be
like he's honest yeah he's on the
spectrum there's something a little odd
about him right instead of hey if you if
you don't stop moving I'm gonna tase you
I'm gonna send a dog after you for guys
to bring him down you know you know
there's gonna be a separate conversation
even about like martial arts trains with
these cops but I think is so [__]
dumb to even have because you guys
should be able to detain a 140-pound
person even if they're will crazy or an
or lane flailing you should be able to
do it period in a story I don't give a
[__] if you haven't trained a day in
your life shut the [__] up but you know
in those type of situations it's like
they can't be it just went straight to 0
to 100 right real quick you're in my
space sir I don't need to tell you what
to do grab them slam into the wall what
in the [__] you know like how is that
situation ok you didn't try to talk to
the kid have a conversation say hey I'm
not trying to detain you I just want to
ask you what's going on you know are you
just dancing or whatever so officer I'm
just I'm just gonna go home cool
well I'm excited to make sure that you
get home the fact that they even felt
like they had the right to question him
yeah that like it go it goes back to
like we have to peel back the layers
right why if you're observing him and
he's walking in a consistent direction
he's dancing listening to music or not
ever what was the problem
what why did you need to intervene I
have to intervene because I have to
control the situation yeah I can't just
allow it to happen no I have to insert
myself and there is this like negative
bias that I think people and I want
people to really think about this too is
because when you see that kid and he's
dancing and they go this conversation
always pops up they say well what if
that cop was wrong and he was a danger
right and next thing you know he's gonna
break into this house and you know rape
these people steal all their money why
the [__] is that popping in your [__]
head
let's start with that - right cuz that's
even though it is like it's innocent
till proven guilty yeah so you can't
arrest someone
what was that stupid what's that stupid
Tom Cruise movie where they try and I
know there's a lot of they're basically
they're trying to predict crimes that
are going to happen Minority Report yeah
sorry if everybody likes that movie you
can't have that you cannot arrest
someone for a crime that they in some
parallel universe may commit right like
in our law state that you are innocent
until proven guilty so even if he was
riding around with a shirt that said
like I'm getting ready to go kill people
technically based on the law you can't
do anything until he actually kills the
people right I'm just thinking about the
the the the bias of like how you can
look at a young black man and assume
that that's where it's going to go you
know that's problem that well even with
George Floyd's case right big ol wall
look at this past right he passed like
did you want that man to go one day go
into your house and rob you and put a
gun next to your pregnant wife it's like
what in the [__] are you talking about
how did you get to that conversation
point and that's not being addressed as
well it's like you went to a very dark
place and for what [__] reason
because black people are not allowed to
change we're not allowed to become
different we're not allowed restorative
justice and retribution does not apply
to us if you're black you have to be
better you have to be stronger you have
to be smarter you have to be faster you
have to be kinder you have to be that
way your whole life you can never have
an off day yeah I can I can never I can
never have a day where I just don't feel
like dealing with anybody you want to
know why because if I do then I will set
the entire black community back 400
years yeah because I'm feeding into
stereotypes right the way yet I have to
give you the benefit of the doubt I have
to give you another chance I had to
forgive you you can have an off day you
can come back and apologize to me I
can't do that what was that film I
watched it was it was like the Bonnie
and Clyde type of film Queen's lamb but
there was a line they said that it was
like there was like they were talking
about black excellence and he goes why
do why do black people always have to be
excellence why yeah why can I just be
you know why it was a very poignant no
it's like literally and I think Khalif
and I haven't talked about this while I
love being black it is exhausting yeah
if I could just get get a vacation and I
can't anything is you're not even safe
in your house because Brianna Taylor was
sleeping in her bed in her home yeah it
was shot and killed she has eight bullet
wounds or more piercing through her body
and she's minding her own freakin
business I'm sorry about to get high I'm
saying like it's just always there's
always a reason for something right when
it comes to black Petes like what were
they doing they were walking they were
sleeping they were blinking or breathing
it's like we were existing why black
well you're basically your list is
running very short now right it's like
at this point now it's any kind of
activity and it doesn't [__] matter
because we could even go into the
conversation of Rashard Brooks right
that Clint - and when I was talking to
Cleef about this is like watch this be a
very very a split topic just because
I've even said I said and people don't
understand watching that clip what the
issue is right they go okay well he ran
away from the cops he started swinging
on them and he tased them and that's why
he got shot number one that doesn't
require for you to be killed period end
of story right and
like they look at that and even within
the black community they go that's the
Troublesome black man I was like but you
do have to watch the previous clip the
other 30 or 40 minutes the conversation
before that where they were trying to
entrap him the whole [__] time and I
was shocked I was like what in the [__]
are you doing like I understand the
situation so this is what happened if
you guys don't know he was at a Wendy's
either he was drunk or he was
intoxicated he was intoxicated he fell
asleep and so he woke back up and then
he's parked his car at the parking lot
in the Wendy's parking lot right so he
was chilling there and he was gonna
sleep call the cops on him for whatever
his for driving under the influence they
approached him and they had this long
conversation and and basically what's
happening in this and I asked the cop
buddy of mine of what's happening he
goes well a lot of the times these cops
when they're in this situation they see
something like this they want the
situation to be a certain way so they
can just go ahead and grab them on
something arrest him and get them out of
there
that goes back to controlling than their
exact lis so these are escalation
tactics these aren't de-escalation
tactics so what's already happening in
those few thirty or forty minutes and
this is my opinion and also an opinion
of a cop that I know where this is what
they were doing they were trying to
escalate the situation to get them on
something so they could just arrest him
and move on so that's why in that clip
they're asking him are you drunk
what did you drink take this
breathalyzer test because they need
those metrics so they could go ahead and
arrest him rather than what the guy said
he was like hey my sister lives right
over there my daughter's right there I'm
drunk how about I leave this car and I
just walk home situation diffused
problem solved take this breathalyzer
instead why don't you try walking or did
you drink what did you drink 30 or 40
[__] times 1020 times I don't [__]
know it was it it was just the point was
incessant I think that's the thing is
like he takes the test he follows your
finger he passes it let him go let him
go like I can see if he was he was sleep
in the park car yes right this wasn't
even he was out driving he parked the
car what you're supposed to do hmm Park
and sleep it off right everybody's been
drunk not everybody's been drunk I've
been drunk plenty of times yes sleep it
off mm-hmm but I think the other thing
is too is that people can always find an
excuse when it's not
him and I say that because how many
times have you slept in a car or fallen
asleep because you were drunk
or what they could have done when a
great cop would have done or a human
being
hey you're drunk but I don't trust you
so I'm gonna drop you off at your
sister's house boom problem solved
nothing was popping off that night he
said it was right around the corner you
could have picked him up and dropped
them off at the [__] house not if you
were that [__] worried about public
safety so there are options there but
they chose to escalate the situation
rather than deescalate it and then you
had this so you know when you look at
those clips you have to take in these
factors like I'm not trying to make an
excuse for Rashard Brooks he was drunk I
understand that I'm not trying to make
an excuse for anything else but the fact
that number one look at the whole
situation you have to look at this it
takes someone to sit down and think
about why this happened if you could do
that if you could do the [__]
research to find incriminating evidence
on somebody then you can do the research
to find why this shouldn't have happened
yeah but it's so easy to ignore that and
I say that because I always go back to
Dylan roof right Dylan roof we know
committed the massacre in in the church
right and it's like twofold right they
knew he was armed they knew he was
dangerous they knew he came they knew
that he admitted to committing a mass
murder right I'm gonna call it Mass
because I feel like one murderer is
already enough but once you get to two
and three and now you're at like what
was it 14 people something ridiculous
murder coroner it's a mass murder they
arrested him took him to get a hamburger
before they took him into custody right
and so I won at a one and you're like
well yeah that's what you should do
because the law says that you're
innocent until proven guilty even if you
admit guilt but then the other part of
me is like no treat him the same way
that you treat unarmed black people
better sleeping what threat was Rashard
Brooks posing what threat was Elijah
posing nothing nothing what they were
unarmed
right Tamir rice was playing with a toy
gun and was killed
he's nine Dylan roof had a real gun or
like a real gun like a real weapon he
admitted to killing people in a church
yet he still the the law worked for him
and I say that because the Constitution
was designed for him it was designed to
protect white Protestant males and if
you want to take it a step further it
was designed to protect white Protestant
rich males because I'm not going to
negate the fact that poverty is its own
separate issue within America but we see
that the justice system we see that
social services we see that the
Constitution works well for the purpose
that it was designed to work the
Constitution was not designed to protect
black people if it was there wouldn't
need there wouldn't have been needed to
be an amendment that abolished slavery
yeah right so we're still we're still
putting our faith in our hope on a
system that was not designed for us this
is why racism is systemic the system was
never designed or created to include us
in it and I don't care how many
amendments you have you're going to have
to continue to have amendments because
the system was never meant to include
you in the first place yeah so in order
to be included you're either going to
have to a completely change it or be
continued to find ways to give yourself
rights yeah I mean it's
I mean we've read all these commerce and
I gotta teach this to fifth graders
fifth graders to believe in a document
that I myself don't believe in let me
not say that I have to agree I have to
teach fifth graders to believe in a
document when I know that for the
majority of my students that document
was not designed with them in mind this
podcast is brought to you by thrive if
you want high quality organic and
non-gmo foods delivered to your door
thrive market is the one for you if
you're still going to the market why
waste your time my friends and
especially that money I know for a fact
you wander aimlessly looking for the
same stuff that for some reason it's
always in a different aisle every time
you go is it magic
is it sorcery it's freaking annoying so
no more a couple of cool things about
being a thrive member you will save 25
to 50% off traditional retail prices and
their shipping is free on orders over
$49 yes I love good deals and food that
I can trust and just like markets you
walk in they also have beauty products
pet staples cleaning products and a
whole bunch more it's really a one-stop
online market shop try thrive market and
become a member
risk free go to thrive market dot-com
genius brain joined today and you'll get
up to $20.00 in shopping credit towards
to our first order that's t H R I ve
market calm / genius brain to start your
risk free membership and get up to $20
towards your first order thrive market
calm / genius brain yeah and I want
people to think about the situation
where and and I'm saying this because
I've you know I read a lot of these
counter-arguments and these
counterpoints and I do want to listen to
what people come from but this is this
is the one of the things like we talked
about the young men who was a mass
murderer you shot up this church they
take him out for a drink
begin I'm a hamburger right they go well
that's not that is a small blip of what
actually happens other people don't get
treated like that cool then you show me
the mass murderer black kid that does
that and he gets the hamburger and the
drink then I want to see that show me
show me that it's an instance that
happens on both sides but you want what
mass murder reply exactly you know why
because if I think it there has been no
first before that or like we keep you
don't have like the thing is is that
none of these situations where people
armed yeah and none of these situations
if if let's say let's say Rashard Brooks
was armed and was trying to shoot the
officers right I get it I get it
okay you shot him because it was shoot
or be shot I get it we're talking about
people losing their lives that are
unarmed that are not posing a threat to
others or themselves and you kill them
and you kill them right like everybody
always has an excuse when it comes to
the injustice of black people yet they
call on us to channel empathy from our
own experiences to help support them
yeah and I say that because the
n-double-a-cp
is the advancement of colored people
because they were in everybody was
colored if you are white you were
colored if you were Asian if you were
Latino hell if you came from Europe Scot
we have to remember Irish people were
considered colored right
there was a specific demographic that
was considered white and everybody else
was wrong hmm so the Advancement of
Colored People was so that everyone can
achieve civil rights women included
right the women's suffrage movement we
oftentimes say this I cannot be a
feminist because the feminist movement
was not inclusive of black women mmm I'm
in a book I'm a proud member of Delta
Sigma Theta Sorority Incorporated we
were founded on January 13 1913 at
Howard University on our founding day by
22 founders walked in the women's
suffrage parade right they were cursed
at they were spit at they had food
thrown at them by white women because
white women weren't advocating for their
rights susan b anthony is mine was she
wanted people like her to get rights to
vote not people like me so I can't be a
feminist because your movement has tried
to disenfranchise me even in the midst
of you need me right for the me too you
need me so that my voice can collect and
less collectively unite with women but
yet while I'm supposed to unite with you
and deal with your struggles of having
sexual misconduct committed against you
you can over a rally Oh
here for me when I need equal pay yeah
right which is a constant conversation
this country was built off of the backs
of black people
everyone civil rights were championed by
black people yet as a black person I am
still fighting for the rights that my
grandmother was fighting for that my
great-grandmother was fighting for I am
tired
we are tired it is exhausting to
continue to either a have to fight for
my rights B explain to people why they
should fight for my rights or C make
myself likeable enough so that people
care enough to at least invest a little
bit of interest in in my quest for
equity solely because of me not because
you care about people not because you're
a good person this is a human rights
issue but solely because you care about
me the other day I put up a picture of
my my daughter right and I used to do
these videos with John Legend good
morning and I will play her like doing
something people love these videos right
and I posted one in the caption at the
bottom said if you care about my
daughter then you have to care about
black lives matter right the response I
got yesterday I posted a video I didn't
have a caption of it was oh girl I'm so
glad that you're posting you know the
videos back of McKenna because you were
getting too political this isn't
political this is my life this is my
kids life so I helped that person out
and I blocked them because I was like
yeah like let me do you a favor let me
room let me remove my burden the burden
of my existence from you right because
you cannot say that you want to see
videos of my daughter but then you can't
care about Brianna Taylor cuz Brianna
Taylor was is somebody's daughter
yeah Brianna Taylor is somebody's sister
Brianna Taylor was McKenna's going to
grow up and I pray I pray I pray I pray
that Devin and McKenna are protected
because there
not enough of us that are looking out
for them well do you think you know
because everybody thinks that they think
it's a personal attack they always think
it's an a personal attack on them they
go black lives matter I care about black
people what the [__] are you talking
about so then you should not have a
problem with black lives mattering
exactly and so and people will bring up
these these issues of like statistics
right they go okay well which beats
statistic is wrong by the way they go
okay well more white people are killed
by cops than black people are well let's
just say your statistic is true right
they're looking at the quantitative data
they're not looking at the actual
percentage exactly and people don't want
any [__] hear that either which is so
obnoxious that would involve using
intelligence exactly and so even when
you bring that up right let's just say
you're right
either way then aren't you dumb aren't
you dumper B no yes yes you be mad with
us then what the [__] are you talking
about so you're the one just getting
[__] over and then you're like well
I'm just taking it so why can't you just
take it yeah what the [__] are you
saying right now like the logic doesn't
make sense either way so that's the
thing too it's just I'm so glad that a
lot of these people who have these
closeted racist feelings you guys are
coming out and you guys are shining
bright right now right and I'm like a
diamond so glad I could see you because
now I can get you know do you a favor
yeah it's above me now I'm blocking you
yeah that was like the greatest clip
ever it's above me now but sir I'm sorry
for calling you it's above me now like
no yeah you you can exit stage left
I'll be straight and and I think um I
think I'm a very I won't say harsh
personality I would say that I'm very
cutthroat in the things that I say right
like it is what it [__] is right and
it's not me and it's like I'm not coming
from a point where I'm not trying to be
empathetic there are people you're
allowed to have your opinion and I want
to listen to it too but now is getting
to the point and I think people have to
understand I don't give a [__]
yeah bit like I'm getting but it's not
an opinion like if you an opinion is I
like McDonald's better than Burger King
right yeah an opinion is not this life
this
our man didn't deserve to die that's not
an opinion that's a fact yeah if you
can't see the fact in that I can't have
this conversation with you and I think
that one of the interesting things is
right we talk about intersectionality
there's even there's discussions and it
was great that you brought it up that
there's it's been divisive within the
black community right the shooting of
Rashard Brooks because my my generation
we're no longer okay with assimilating
yeah right whereas for my mom's
generation the fight was so much about
integration that they felt like once
they got integrated they had to fall in
line with everybody else you know the
great dr. Martin Luther King his vision
his dream was not that black people
would then try and live up to the
illogical standards of white society or
Western society it was that we would
have our place and representation and
value in this society and how it's got a
misinterpreted is there are so many
things about being black specifically a
black woman I've never been a black man
so I can't talk to you about that but as
a black woman to even our hair right
when I first started deciding to go
natural which is basically deciding like
the fact that the natural hair movement
is even a thing yeah it shows you how
how far behind we still are right you
never have to sit I have sat across from
women who have their hair dyed bright
pink and yet I have to have a
conversation about the curls that come
out of my natural hair or in my natural
head yeah
your hair is pink bruh if anybody the
the focus should be directed on you or
even the idea that your natural hair is
unkempt yeah you it was I mean my family
comes from the south right so I mean
they really some of the things they
really got in them and one of the things
is
you can't walk around here looking like
a [__] that is what my ganna used
to say breasts makes you recipes
you cannot come out here looking like a
[__] why are you not straightening
your hair and luckily as she got older
and I learned how to do my hair because
I will admit I didn't know how to do my
natural hair at first why because I
started going to the beauty salon and
getting my hair straightened when I was
two
oh that early yeah in I have an 80s
black mama so they really liked there
was no there was no like oh let me try
no it either was straight or it wasn't
and if it wasn't they were gonna make it
straight yeah and one of the things I've
been super intentional about with
raising a daughter is I don't want
McKenna to straighten her hair unless
she wants to but I want her to feel
comfortable looking at her hair the way
it comes out of her head and thinks that
she's still beautiful right so then I
have to do the same yeah I have to be
willing to be that mirror reflection and
have my hair and braids or switch it up
I mean I'm a hair switcher upper right
but the fact that it even has to be a
conversation why are you watching why
are you that pressed I'm not watching
you but it's because magnifying glass is
pointed on us for everything that we do
that is black and is not white because
everyone is trying to assimilate - what
- what the standard is and what they
feel like society dictates as the norm
and so just the color of my skin already
makes me the anti norm and that's that's
such an interesting thing to bring up
too because I think like within like the
Asian community there is this problem of
them acquainting like white whiteness as
something of like royalty almonds right
so there's like this topic where you
know my buddy Joe mentioned - I was like
why do you think it is that a lot of
these Asian guy's not our Asian friends
right but these people from like other
states they [__] obsessed with
gaining the white girl right they're
like why are you so obsessed with
getting a white woman right you know
what because they think that not all
sorry it's like you think that just
because you're with a white woman that
you won this prize that now you're going
to be accepted into this this royalty of
whiteness now well let me tell you this
like either way the
reason why I want Asian people to
understand that you do have to take a
stand in this situation and you coasting
in the middle doesn't work anymore
because you have to look at the
situation this country's in and on top
of that aren't you a little bit tired of
being used as the the model minority to
be pitted against somebody else right
like aren't you you want to be a [__]
for the rest of your [__] life is
just that don't forget black people got
a little bit of a break when kovat hit
right yeah I'm supposed to be up in arms
about the conch flu which I am because
that's racist AF like yeah nobody should
be saying that but if we only had to
deal with confluent you have to do like
getting nooses put in our garages at
NASCAR races because we're tired of seen
the Confederate flag like it pales in
comparison and and I think that's that's
the other thing right is that we're not
saying everybody has it easy hell why
people don't have it easy it is hard
life is hard but some people's lives are
harder than others yeah exactly
and so you know that situation - like I
I you know I bring up that clip of just
Trump just sitting there and he goes he
says kung flu right and I reason the
reason why I say this - is like if you
ever think that for a moment just
because you stay in line then it makes
you closer to white people which means
enemy
watch this [__] though you watch that
[__] of Trump going conch flew and you
hear this church a pillar of
Christianity start cheering their
[__] heads off so now you really know
what they actually think about you and
if you're still okay with that you got
to check yourself on that stuff it's
like well maybe if I stay quiet you know
they're not gonna really [__] with me
you think that's what it is right now
you're a slave in your own home and you
don't even see it don't even see it you
don't [__] see it passing yeah but
the thing is is that eventually the line
of oppression has to the pendulum has to
swing back which it did yeah you can
only escape oppression for so long when
it's systemic and it's true - because
these emotions - just to bring him back
to the Cova thing it's like if you were
on par and equal to this so there's
whiteness that you saw when this Cova
situation happened you I wouldn't have
walked down and have somebody say you
people to me it wouldn't have happened
it just wouldn't have happened because
it's like no because I'm your people
right I thought we're we're cool no and
you're sitting there and you want to be
put on this pedestal saying like well
look at these black people and how they
behave [__] they don't see you
as equals
you're they see you beneath them too but
they just you as more obedient exactly
and I it bothers me so much that people
can't recognize that [__] it's like
you're just a little [__] lapdog and
you don't see it it's like hey remember
this - it's like it's like they go okay
well Asian people came to this country
and they opened up because we were
allowed to the word is allow as I was
just that as there are two groups of
people who felt colonization the worst
indigenous Americans because they were
hearing mine in their business and
didn't need anybody to come over here
right yeah Columbus already tried he did
his damage they were like okay we got
through that one oh no we're going to
lose our entire country and second I
don't know if this was not made clear in
fifth grade history but as a fifth-grade
teacher slaves were not immigrants we
did not come over here willingly yes we
weren't building communities we weren't
escaping oppression what people say go
back to where you came from I would love
to because we were fine y'all saw black
panther like black panther basically
what Conda is an African civilization
that was able to escape colonialism like
if you really want to get deep with it
that's why it was so moving was not be I
mean Marvel's just the best anyway I'm a
die-hard Marvel that was one thing but
it also was like dang this really could
have been us right like go back to where
you came from I don't want to be here
the first place y'all granddaddy brought
me over here build me the ship and put
it back
and I'm not saying on the Middle Passage
I need an ocean balcony I need crab legs
like do it right do it right we did not
come here using crab legs
all the things you could ask crab legs
yeah the funniest negotiator I [__]
like what do you want
crab leg that's like no you could ask
for a little more ask for some more but
I'm saying the bare minimum the ocean
balcony and not not just crab legs I
want king crab legs I want the drum
butter right and give boiling crab to
ship is some of the whole shebang so I
could dip it in there right like haha
like there's there's definitely gonna be
a writer with my quest back to Africa
notion that like I was watching this
clip this is why Facebook I keep trying
to delete facebook and I only keep it
because I've had Facebook since I was in
college and I need to put all of my
pictures off of there and just delete it
cuz I'm sick of it but Facebook is also
beneficial because somehow people find
the archives of like old stuff so
there's this old Donahue clip right and
he had Minister Louis Farrakhan on it
and I say this because black people can
be so divisive within ourselves because
people always look at Louis Farrakhan
and I'm not gonna call him Alcala
Malcolm X Malik el-shabazz they look at
him they look at them as the oh my gosh
you're black supremacist right first of
all black supremacy doesn't exist it
doesn't it can't why because we're not
given enough power to be supreme over
anybody we're still we're still just
trying to push our way at the table
which I hope that we get sick of it and
just decide to build our own table make
it bigger and better and over everybody
else and just do our own thing right but
I was watching this clip and I was like
dang so Donahue has this audience and
it's white and black and they have them
segregated right and he's talked to
Minister Farrakhan and you know the
people are like sir you seem so educated
you seem so educated but your ideas
scare me if something that he said was
so deep he was like do you know what
you're scared you're not scared because
of what you think I'm going to do you're
scared because you think that I'm going
to learn from you
or ancestors what to do and I was like
dang that's deep because his notion was
if you even let's move on to sixth-grade
history if you remember sixth-grade
history right we study all the ancient
civilizations the common thread because
between all of these ancient
civilizations is the fact that the end
of these civilizations came through
colonization through brute force through
genocide through power struggles through
the stripping of culture it's not so
much that white people are afraid to
make us equal they're afraid of people
of color using the tactics that they
used to get power right the Boston Tea
Party was a riot they were looting they
were destroying public property you want
me to teach my students about how white
people dressed up as indigenous
Americans stole tea and threw it out in
the harbor and that's supposed to be the
reclaiming of American freedom right but
then when people do that in Oakland and
they just don't happen to be white then
it's something terrible we learned this
from you this behavior was learned and
modeled from you this country was
created through stealing you stole and
you you committed genocide against
people and then you have the nerve then
you have the nerve to want to have the
right to bear arms and protect your land
this isn't your land you are on stolen
land you are on stolen land this land
what you're trying to control does not
belong to you which is why it will
always be a power struggle because you
know deep down inside as you walk across
this street that you are walking across
the dead bodies of people who were the
inhabitants of this land I think that
conversation of
of why things happen on a systemic level
is just it's based on the foundation of
this country right yeah and then people
don't want to have that conversation and
it's because people like the people that
don't want it to change are the ones
that don't have to have these struggles
they like it they're like what's the
problem it's like well there is no
problem for you or you for you right and
so privileged and so and people hate
hearing that too because they constantly
feel like well what am I doing wrong
it's like it's not so much you it's not
like you walked out today right you saw
a black person and then you call them
the n-word and then you walked off but
that's what you think people are saying
to you and that's not what it is you
just have to understand there are
certain behavior so there's certain
things that you are allotted that a lot
of other people in this country don't
have nobody's asking you to grovel at
your feet to another culture but you
have to understand the playing field
isn't equal and so when you see your
other human being right that's going
through the struggle that's where that's
where there's this disconnect for me is
where you could watch this stuff and be
okay with it and just say whatever and
then walk away I'm asking people to look
at it on a human level first if you can
do that then maybe it'll open your eyes
in your heart to something else but
because you refuse to do that because it
doesn't affect you on on a personal
scale that's all right it in itself of a
problem because you're not going to want
to learn you're not gonna want to see
this stuff
it doesn't equate to you groveling at
somebody else's issues or at their feet
nobody's asking for that and I know for
a fact that you feel that way you feel
that if you do that it takes something
familiar rather than you gaining
knowledge and perspective you think it's
taken that that's true they're just just
hearing that just makes me think of like
people about privilege like you're so
accustomed to privilege that oh that
equality feels like oppression hmm
listen to you guys love that you are so
used to privilege that equality feels
like a prep can we write that like that
[Laughter]
hey low-key now you leave some of the
profits though I'm just taking some of
these things the my story liner right
with you guys were saying just I like
how to have to make people feel
comfortable by when how you look at my
skin you feel like the classic higher
learning in the class and in the
elevator you know I see a white women
are person you know a person that's not
color like for some color I know what I
have to do to make you feel comfortable
hmm I have to speak eloquently in a way
that you're not used to but you expect
so that I don't know my vernacular is
like a talismanic I you know yeah hi how
are you doing today exactly the weather
is really great outside you know what's
amazing
you know what's crazy - it's like I I
can I for a fact know that these type of
things are a learn [__] behavior
because I do it on the flip side right
it's like when I ever see a black woman
I feel comfortable you know I grew up in
a beauty supply store so it's like
that's all I saw growing up so my
behavior accustoms do that because i
feel comfortable and loose but when I
see a white person I get [__] nervous
you know I mean I feel like I'm doing
something wrong just when you see your
cup yeah right like I feel like even
today I don't know why but there's a
bunch of cops out right by immediately
enough oh yeah no I noticed yeah you
noticed alert like bang I'm pulling up
in this Lexus with this dark tinted
windows and all the reason why my
windows are tinted so dark is so people
cannot see inside yeah because before I
had it tart before I had its in too dark
I got pulled over yeah a lot same yeah
yeah a lot I have to break the law to
protect myself yeah I don't know I need
to get my windows tinted is the truth
because I mean like even the fact what
Callie said about privilege right I'm
privileged I have like I cannot sit up
here and pretend like my life has been
struggles and yeah I'm privileged I'm
privileged socioeconomically and I say
that because I can live in my little
microcosm in my community and be super
comfortable in the suburbs right I can't
do that though there's there's has to be
more to it and even within this struggle
there's still certain aspects that I
can't relate to right I can't relate to
the struggle of being black and in
poverty I didn't grow up in the hood I
grew up
and that's the other thing to write is
that you cannot look at you cannot look
at what is the fluke my family is the
fluke coming from a family of African
Americans who are I'm not gonna say
African Americans because now I have the
understanding that there are truly
African Americans and there's black
Americans so I come from a black
American family that has been privileged
to receive an education prior to my
generation in my mom's generation right
going back to my grandparents generation
they were privileged there was a fluke
somebody ended up being able to start
owning property they were able to own
property when they came out here my
grandparents paid off their house they
were able to open up a business this was
not the norm this was a slight what is
that like my baby brain when you have
like they they talked about in like the
matrix where there's like the way that
things are supposed to go and there's
like a slight like gonna nominally it's
an anomaly thank you thank you that's
not Whitney high school education Amelie
and what often times people do is they
try to use this anomaly and make it like
oh no but this is this is what you could
have happened Noah's not because their
family situation they didn't have
someone who just happened to be gracious
enough to allow them to have something
that gave them a head start right I even
look at my husband my mom was a single
parent my mother-in-law I have two but
one is deceased she was a single parent
right or hurt my father-in-law and her
were not together and she had she had
like the primary custody of my husband
we grew up with what looks like the same
situation very different by the time I
was born my mom already had her master's
degree she had been teaching she had had
10 years she had a career she had a job
right my mom and my mother-in-law I'll
just say AMA they were the same age my
husband is nine yet nine months younger
than me he'll call me a cougar but it's
only nine months right but people will
compare the
situations but the fact that my mom had
a career was already completed graduate
school and Alma had not gave my husband
and I very different upbringing yeah she
had to break her back and work multiple
jobs to put him in private school then
at one point she couldn't afford to put
him in private school she put him in the
like local neighborhood school in
southeast [__] he's gonna say four
corners I'm gonna represent for him and
eventually was like you're going to if I
continue to let you go to the school
you're gonna end up in jail so then she
paid someone in La Jolla to use their
address so that he can go to high school
in La Jolla right or even eighth grade
he went to eighth grade at La Jolla and
then he ended up going to UTC which is a
school in La Jolla right I always went
to great schools I went to private
school it's still my mom deemed that
public school was acceptable for me and
then I went to a great public school
there was never a doubt in my mind that
I was going to college College was not
an option like it was it was like it was
elementary Whitney College for Hunter it
was a very big deal to AMA
and to my father-in-law and to my other
mother-in-law Bridget who we call
mamacita it was imperative to them but
they were like no you have to go to
college it would the gunner will tell
you like there was a part where he was
like dang I may not get it it never
dawned on me that I would not get into
college yeah and that's that's a huge
conversation to even to just talk about
generational wealth in this country and
even even for like Asian Americans if I
wanted to help them relate to because I
feel like that's my responsibility it's
like I remember when I just going to
college and just even applying to
college how difficult it was for me
right and then I would have conversation
with some of these other kids whose
parents had lived here for a long time
they helped him with the college
applications they knew about
scholarships they had connections with
their alma mater and stuff like that I'm
like the [__] is our alma mater like you
got to apply us I don't know how to
apply to this stuff I had to figure this
[__] out and my brother had to figure it
out on his own first we had to figure
out about scholarships we didn't know
any of this stuff my parents didn't
[__] know the stuff either so could
you imagine how different my life would
have been if my parents had that leg up
right and we talked about people people
don't understand how fortuitous it is to
have somebody like that in your life
that knew these type of things we did it
or that did it themselves like that's a
bigger thing yeah
like it was not there's there's been a
direct blueprint for how I'm supposed to
navigate life by the majority of my
family members that is not the norton
like Khalif Khalif didn't grow up like
that yeah and we went to the same number
one high school in California even
though y'all number three now but
whatever which is probably will we we
got to get back we got to circle around
the way we got to get back to that but
like for Khalif right we're both black
we both grew up in the same community
completely different experiences yeah
and that's the thing too they try to
take your example of quote/unquote what
they say is like what an anomaly exactly
then they go well look at her that's
what she did but that doesn't represent
the other 99% and sometimes people who
live in your situation they'll take that
stance of well I did it and they try to
shame their own culture for it which is
so [__] of knowledge line if I said
that I didn't do it if I did not become
because that was what my gauge was right
even in even with Khalif and I being as
close as we were in high school and like
being his big sister
there are things now where I was like
ding that was super not culturally
insensitive but I'll say
socioeconomically insensitive I grew up
with other black girls who had the same
and black friends that had the same set
up as I did yeah I felt like the
underdog because my parents were
divorced right their parents were
together they had these beautiful homes
when we were 16 we all got our cars yeah
we all were going to go to good colleges
right it wasn't until I got to Cal State
Long Beach where I had other black
friends that let me know very quickly we
weren't going to roost Chris for my 18th
birthday yes I was like what do you mean
what do you mean guys yeah
hey man we got Bruce what is Bruce Chris
first of all I just heard fabulous rap
about the other song man hey we don't
take you to TGI Fridays we don't split
like three different entrees
yeah we'll you know like you just have
to pay for dessert but like I had to
check my own privilege college was a big
experience for me too because I grew up
so disadvantaged right and then you go
to this place and I remember just even
something small right there like yeah
man
what are you gonna go for summer I'm
like oh okay what do you mean like
vacation like I'm like what the [__] a
vacation what are you saying
you know I mean like I'm gonna go home
and I'm gonna chill at home be like oh
we're gonna go to [__] Egypt we're
gonna go I was like boy I look how much
is that some bait but they're looking at
me like like I'm [__] crazy and I'm
there was a few and the people that I
connected with the most in that school
were people who were in my socioeconomic
status good they understood what what's
up they understood how it was to be
broke and what we were gonna do when we
go back home but having conversations
with them their life growing up was so
[__] different like I remember how
would you share small stories right and
they were like yeah I mean when I was a
kid and my parents will ground me I'm
like what would you do is that you would
go to your room and they would you do
nothing I'm like yeah but one day get
socked know my parents would it hit me I
was like hey doctor yeah tell me well
how bad did they hit you I'm like they
wouldn't hit me I'm like what happened
to you my dad threw a office chair in my
head another time he kept me down some
steps man this is life was good I love
my parents you know we're good but those
are like this situation that they
wouldn't relate to and they wouldn't
understand and so for me to like I had
to learn how to especially being on this
space because of my I think very in
terms of privilege I think of how I got
to grow up around a lot of diverse
cultures a lot of other Asian kids who
grew up in areas where there's not a lot
of Asian people
I was very dismissive of how they grew
up they're like oh like why people they
would say my white people don't do that
[__] I was like if they do [__] my
school just beat that and nightlife is
good but that's hard when the four Asian
people in the school of all white people
and they
pulled their eyes back they go ching
chong ching chong and then you just got
a smile and go along with it or you're
the guy then this is know how to take a
[__] joke and to me I didn't I
couldn't recognize that until I started
travelling to these colleges and I'm
like oh you guys had to start up this
Asian Club because you're trying to find
out your culture within this school it's
a small little microcosm of this huge
universe of white people and you just
got it you want to feel home here and
you don't have that home so that's why
you had this agent Club where you had
these corny ass sayings of like what's
the cult like we're ice power and I just
want to shoot me in my [__] face but
you know I understand why you do it
I understand why you guys have like you
know right dude they have some babies
once cool once gave me a shirt with like
a got rice guys saying Asian club I was
like I've worn this [__] t-shirt
right now but you know that's this them
it is them exploring what they what they
have you know they have a lot of these
like weird little slogans that I
personally don't like not judging
oh I'm judging out loud I'm judging like
a [__] but you know what though
I mean it's go do what you got to do in
you and I think that's the thing is that
you have to do you have to do what you
have to do yeah if that makes you feel
like a little more connected to yourself
and that helps you find that community I
understand like so I understand it now
like going to these colleges really did
open up my eyes it's like [__] like your
experience wasn't mine that's why I
could walk around I could say all the
[__] about Asian people backed them up
and I could be brazen about how I feel
because I had a culture in a community
that allowed me to feel that way
they they supported me they're like it's
okay to do that it's okay that I could
bring chopsticks to school and if you
don't [__] like it I'll stick these
in your [__] eye you know I could say
these things but for them if they did
they got outed out they were ostracized
they weren't made fun of it doesn't
allow them to be strong with their voice
we even saw that clip of a young girl
who walked out with her black lives
matter poster yeah and I forgot what
state or city it was in but it was a
bunch of people grabbing at her signs
and you have an idea how brave that is
for her to do that for her for her to go
down the understand that I am one out of
a thousand people that I'm gonna speak
up for something that I believe in that
other people don't
it's crazy sense also I can't remember
where was but I mean at some point I
have to stop watching it just so that I
don't end up shocking people what it is
I don't want to lose my job I mean I
definitely you know it's Brigance have I
mean the thing is is a lie
even everybody's biased right and I say
that because I have my own bias and of
course and it's been really hard for me
to take the role of an activist and use
the intersectionality that I have to
empower and to channel it in towards
positivity because there was a point
where I literally had to look at
pictures of close friends in mind that I
really care about that were white and
remind myself that not all white people
are bad it gets to that point this was
last week and I'm not like it really
gets at that point because it's so easy
to just write it all off because it's so
exhausting and I've even had to I mean
in conversations to having to remind
myself of my own privilege right my
socio-economic privilege because that
place that plays a huge role in factor
like you were saying right Cerritos is
this own microcosm because it's diverse
culturally but now socioeconomically
like you I mean you can't you can't live
in Cerritos and survive off a chunk
change yeah so you're with people that
you have the privilege of accepting
their culture because that's all you're
having to accept yeah
whereas if you are culturally different
and socioeconomically different I cannot
fathom or imagine how much it sucks to
go to school in Cerritos mmm and school
should not be like that yeah and school
I mean and it's so engrained within
within our school system like how john
was talking about right like the school
the american public school system is
systemically disenfranchising students
of color if you just want to look at the
bare basics of curriculum we won't even
get into funny we'll just look at
curriculum right curriculum is solely
geared to highlighting one story one
culture one
one narrative the only time that really
you do an in-depth study of ancient
world civilizations and I say ancient
because there's not any there's no
classes that you take even world history
where you're discussing current world
history it's all ancient it's all in the
past which then removes you from it
removes you from truly connecting with
the little bit of representation that
you see of yourself and your culture in
curriculum yeah and that's strategic
right because you study how bit like how
much US history can we study right the
United States has only really been in
existence for a little under five
hundred years right so how many
different ways can I split up George
Washington being the first president of
the United States yeah or you know I'm
not even let's just bypass the 1800s but
like there's only so many times you can
discuss that yet in school curriculum
it's covered in history classes so many
times you take world history twice you
take world history in sixth grade you
take it in tenth grade yeah every other
type of history is you do California
history and fourth grade
everything else is US history US history
passed to 1865 u.s. history present 1865
to current US history Pat like you ji
mean we get it it's interesting to how I
want to say the word interesting I'm
just being nice about it [__] up how
like it's [__] up how black American
history is such an integrated part and
an integral part of this country and
it's just glossed over and is this week
chapter I will tell you in scott
foresman
US history fifth grade book it is one
and a half lessons in unit six that's
crazy
and it's so glossed over that I don't
even want to
the glossary taxes this one but it's
glossed over because what are you gonna
say yes we illegally stole people on the
land that we stole we went to another
country or continent we went to another
continent but I say country because
predominantly the Middle Passage set off
from Ghana and came over whatever we
went to a country in Africa we stole
people and then brought them here and
forced them to build this country they
never say it like that like the way they
painted is oh we went to Africa and
there was a slave trade and then the
slaves came over here and then they
fought for their silver rice button like
literally that is such a small thing and
even for my school right I mean however
culturally diverse it is I found about
Juneteenth to an Atlanta episode you
know I mean like I didn't know about
that [__] until I saw Atlanta you want
to know why because Abraham Lincoln
freed the slaves with emancipation so
there's just like all this stuff because
you did not have black history without
the white hero yeah and I say this
because I will always I am solely a
teacher because of mr. David Bohannon
who was my AP US teacher and on the
first day of school he said George
Washington was a liar Thomas Jefferson
owned slaves and Abraham Lincoln didn't
free them this was 11th grade and I was
like the blasphemy yeah but then when
you find out you're like yeah I can't
declare china to be a democratic nation
when they're not a part of the United
States of America at the time when
Abraham Lincoln wrote the Emancipation
Proclamation the south has seceded from
the Union they were the Confederacy they
weren't fooling with us yeah well you
basically free slaves in a land that you
didn't own yeah it was political sorry
Abe you cool and all you know recipes
but like you didn't do anything but yet
you're supposed to be the savior and
then after that we celebrate Juneteenth
because those slaves weren't even free
yeah they weren't free unless I'm saying
like it's I want to I just don't
understand
how like we said American history is so
short because a country has a minion for
that long and you get if people don't
really believe that you're [__] dumb
go to any other country and you'll see
how deep their history goes specifically
Europe see how far their history goes
you see it in their landmarks America
looks like the trashiest country on
earth when you go from coast to coast
like they just figured it out as long as
they were going yeah the roads in the
East Coast are [__] terrible and it
gets better and better and better and
better as you go towards the west this
country was informed that [__]
longboats Destiny reckon like manifest
like this is not that Oh God
the fact that the civil rights Union or
the civil rights Union the civil rights
movement ended 52 years ago 52 nothing
wrong no Ruby Bridges is 65 years old
she's still living do you know what's
crazy and Frank Martin Luther King and
Barbara Walters were all born the same
year Barbara Walters if you look at
pictures of Barbara Walters from 1968
1969 she is in color right the civil
rights movement there are color pictures
the reason why they change the pictures
from colored to black and white is to
have us trick our minds this is not a
conspiracy theory this is real they have
as trick our minds to think that it was
so long ago Barbara Walters was on the
air when Martin Luther King did that I
have a dream speech like she was a
journalist Barbara [__] Walters but
do you see what I'm saying though well
that's what it's like that's nice this
is a huge point that I brought up to it
was like I don't understand why people
think the civil rights movement is it's
[__] ancient history because the
pictures are black and white didn't that
tell you David I know like a white is so
[__] funny to me
when people talk about that right and I
and I make this comparison our parents
were alive during the civil rights
movement I make my grandfather's mother
they've been through four thousand Wars
and stuff that [__] his first
pet was a [__] Tyrannosaurus Rex
that's all well he died now recipes
but it's me grandpa i straight-up
mention this - it's like they talk about
the civil rights movement right and they
go do you realize like that happened now
so why are people still complaining
about racism let me tell you how I've
done that [__] thing is this is let
me just explain to you why it I'm not
just making this [__] up I'm reading the
[__] online all the [__] time and it
irritates the [__] out of me and the
reason why I say this is so stupid
there was a statement you need a
vacation but recent no it's just me but
recently there was something that was
put out that we were supposed to do as a
nation that everybody was supposed to
follow right and nobody should be
opposed of it because it's the President
of the United States the CDC said that
we should do this wear a mask how many
people wore a [__] mask how many so
if we're talking about things that are
put in place that people should follow
in this country that if it is put in
place people fall it to the tee wearing
a mask didn't happen how wearing a mask
is a violation of my civil rights how
easy do you think it was for a bunch of
people who look at black Americans as
chattel and property to be like okay
you're good now we're fine and they were
just gonna walk away and everything was
going to be copacetic they just got
smarter they just found ways to make it
a lot like my students you have slavery
abolished you have the Thirteenth
Amendment literally hand in hand no
coincidence right some of the very same
laws that are ruling our country today
were a response of the Confederacy to
come back to the Union like the Civil
War was fought because half of y'all did
in I mean I'm not gonna say this PG the
only reason why the North truly didn't
care about they didn't fight the Civil
War because of slavery they fought the
Civil War because they were upset that
the South left the United States right
slavery was not beneficial in the north
because it was not profitable the reason
why slavery was so profitable in the
south is because the South farming
conditions allowed for them to farm
year-round to have large property and
large land and grow crops in in massive
numbers right you can't do that in the
Northeast
especially now in the fall and the
summer or the fall in the winter so
slavery was not beneficial to them and I
say that because this was not fought
over this is slavery is wrong it was
fought because they were like again oh
when you signed on to this constitution
you sign your colony say that you were
gonna be a part of the United States of
America you don't just get to up and
leave like that it was for power so even
the Civil War it wasn't some grandiose
stance against we care about these
Africans that you stole no y'all did it
y'all just didn't like the fact that
they were saying peace we're out of here
having the cake immediate - yeah like
you don't just see it think about it as
bitter excess the Civil War was an
argument between bitter exes right you
don't get to up and leave me you get
back over here
would I say like that me is what it was
we'll see this you know what that's how
we're gonna teach this actually why and
I don't understand why in curriculum why
is that a problem for people to teach
this part of history the way it's
supposed to be right because then you
would have to admit that America is not
perfect oh you don't know that you would
say let me tell you something if Donald
Trump said make America great I could
get on that slogan again what has it
been great this is this is I'm proud to
be an American no I'm like why I was
stolen I was forced to be an American
and I still got to deal with the BS that
my ancestors had to deal with and it's
and it's such a sad thing to say when I
the reason why Donald Trump has support
that I'm not a communist McCarthy the
reason why Donald Trump has a lot of
support is because he's saying stuff to
that people that he knows will vote a
lot agree with ya you know he's not
gonna say the stuff that people disagree
with that that's his voting power but
the sad thing is is that's the majority
and people don't see that as a problem
that he could say stuff like kung flu
say a lot of just racially insensitive
things and people cheer that on and they
go there's cut you
have a problem with racism I was like
that's so funny because the president
reflects those views and you are
bolstering those opinion and the reason
why you vote from is because he reflects
your ideals like that's very plain and
simple there's no argument behind that
what is there to argue behind that you
know what helps me sleep at night though
and I have to remind myself of this
Donald Trump is only president because
of the antiquated electoral college he
did not do he did not win the popular
vote and that right there allows me to
be optimistic and restores my faith in
humanity is he we can't even call it dog
whistling right Ronald Reagan had the
dog whistle down pat so did Richard
Nixon Donald Trump is just blazing with
it which is cool like I would rather you
stab me in the heart and stab me in the
back cuz at least I could see the knife
coming and I know how I know how to move
right the thing about it is that Donald
Trump's initial win was only because he
still didn't won the popular vote right
but he was speaking to people who are we
have to acknowledge the fact that white
Americans and poverty are also
marginalized and I don't take that away
from them there are many parts of this
country and rural areas where they are
suffering just as much as black
Americans not suffering the same because
they may not have the same threat as
being unarmed and being murdered by
police officers but they have their fair
share of problems that equates the level
of pain and tribulations that they're
going through he was speaking to them
because they he had to be divisive and
separate them because they can't get
with the black lives matter movement
because they're not black right or this
is from their thinking right but they're
like dang I'm poor my children don't
have clean drinking water my children
are suffering from a poor education yet
the only people that they seem to care
about are people of color
so you're speaking to me because you're
telling me that I'm seen yeah
so on that aspect I get it which is also
why
I was a Poli Sci major and I have my I
have my BA in Poli Sci right and I say
that because I originally wanted to go
to law school and I always look in the
kale cuz Nikhil's a really good friend
of Mines and I'm like and I have another
good friend Gary who Gary is black and
he is in the he's an assistant district
attorney and then you haven't killed as
a public defender right and I look at
both of them I'm like I don't know how
you do your jobs I don't know how you
can possibly convict innocent people and
then I don't know how you can possibly
get off guilty people right I don't have
it cut out to me in me to be a lawyer
because I don't have faith in the system
and I don't have faith in the system
because the system has failed people not
just black people not just people of
color but it has also failed poor white
Americans right there should you should
never have a country where people are
extremely wealthy and then you have some
that don't have access to what should
just be basic human rights a home food
clean water and a good education so I
get it and I think that's also what gets
lost a lot of times is as a black woman
and as a marginalized person who's off
who has to spend the majority of my
waking hours fighting for my rights I
can empathize with other marginalized
disenfranchised groups maybe not the
same I can't I don't I don't know how it
is to be poor I'm not gonna pretend to
say I do but what I can't say is I know
how it feels to be oppressed and I know
how it feels to be ignored in the same
way that I want you to support me and
get people to recognize that my life as
a black woman matters I also want to
support you and say that I should not
you should not have to worry about where
your next meal is coming from and if we
find a way to use our own respective
experiences to unite
can truly eradicate a lot of the issues
and the problems that we have but as
long as we still continue to look at
them as separate issues as long as I
still continue to say black lives matter
and your responses all lives matter
yeah I'm saying all lives matter I'm
just reminding you that black people
have to be included in that conversation
the same way that when you say I
shouldn't be poor and I'm like I mean
I'm fine I'm eating well over here
everybody has food there everybody has
good like basically this is like telling
a poor person everybody has access to
grocery stores yeah there may be a
grocery store but I don't have the money
to pay for the food yeah this is like
going to saying all lives matter is like
going to a Breast Cancer Walk and being
like brain cancer matters like yeah it
does but we're not talking about that
right now yeah all cancer matters find a
cure for everybody yeah but nobody
nobody seems to realize that and it's
because we're all so focused on our own
struggles that we can't use our
struggles to allow us to understand
someone else's and just I just don't
like the corrective behavior of trying
to tell somebody who has a movement for
something that affects them right in
their whole community to come in and say
hey how about you not say black lives
matter and just say all lives matter
that corrective behavior to me is
already say that's and white people [__]
it is some white people [__] but you
have to remember because from their from
their historical standpoint right
anytime that they have felt like
something mattered it has not just
mattered its brain supreme yeah it's
dictated Society yeah so these words are
triggering because historically this is
what has caused them to my farm matters
what are you gonna do I'm gonna go to
Africa and I'm gonna kidnap me some
slaves like that's that's the result
right is that because I matter my
mattering is makes everyone else
subservient so when they hear matters
that trigger word automatically gets
them to think oh no you're trying to
come for me yeah one of the biggest
behaviors
specifically and you know some of the
white friends that I know and it's not
that I'm there to correct it but I do
shut that [__] down it's it's that it's
that behavior right there it's that they
sometimes feel and it's not on purpose
but when people we have a group
conversation let's say it's something as
simple as this hey what do you guys want
to eat 9 out of 10 people go where we
want to go to the seafood joint and then
that one person is using that white
person and they go well I don't like it
because of this this and that choose
something else you're 1 out of 10 shut
the [__] up but yeah but that's that's
what I'm talking about is with the
privilege right is that because you
don't want it you think that the nine
other people who have come to common
consensus exactly and so like even with
this person it's just like I don't know
how many times I can tell you to shut
the [__] up you know I mean and what I'm
trying to tell you right now is that
collectively you have to look at the
group as a whole that your opinions are
not facts that is that you form your
opinions are not [__] I really
appreciated a and so that's yeah that's
the [__] that always that has always
gotten under my skin it's like how come
it when we have an open conversation
about how we feel about opinions your
thing always ways above mine and if I
don't listen to it I'm the dumb one in
the group if we're talking about
opinions flavors of food whatever who
the [__] cares but you walk away feeling
like you're being drowned out because
your opinion wasn't considered as a fact
and you feel like now you're missing
something that's wrong it's the wrong
behavior in a group setting in a
personal setting that's not okay if not
and you know just bringing that up it
[__] with them a little bit it [__]
with their whole thing is is that I took
a class at Cal State Long Beach I took a
Women's Studies class because I was just
like I'm gonna do these GES but I'm
gonna do these GES the way I want to do
them so I ended up I ended up claiming
pan-african Studies as my second major
and so I ended up getting my um my
bachelor's degree in pan-african Studies
as well but one of the classes I took
was a half
kind of woman ism class right so it was
it was talking about being black and
being a womanís in a womanist is the
movement behind Womanism is to make it
equitable for women and men not to shut
down men's voices right because men are
still men should still be respected men
are still very important parts of
society we don't want to shut you down
we want to rise and be in power with you
so that's the whole theory behind woman
ISM in the class the first day the
teacher asked us to identify ourselves
hi Megan I'm a junior you know blah blah
blah right everybody else goes to the
introductions and she stopped after the
introductions that she said what I want
you to notice black women is that this
is probably the first time that you've
never had to identify your race or your
gender in a class because you're the
majority and when I stopped and I
thought about it I was like Karen said
that she's caring and she's white but
she didn't say she was a woman Michael
said he was white and Mail Davis said
I'm a Korean male because this is the
first time and not specifically for like
David but this is this is the first time
for Karen and Bobby where they're not in
the majority hmm and when you are used
to live in life not in the majority you
never have to be considerate of everyone
else who is in the the minority yeah and
that was something that always resonated
with me right because I was like dang
that's true because the way long beach
was was like you would have these huge
lecture halls but a Long Beach State was
really good about you know having some
classes that were like pretty intimate
like 30 to 40 kids right
and so this especially in the Africa
pan-african Studies department right a
whole lot of people weren't taking
pan-african Studies classes and
I realize now that the reason why I took
those classes was because I felt seen it
wasn't so much that yes I had I mean you
can't learn from dr. Maulana Karenga
who's the you know creator of Kawana he
was so active as a part of snick in the
civil rights movement and not be like I
mean the fact that dr. Krank is still
teaching right like that's crazy that's
insane yeah but I took those classes
because I was like dang this is the
first time that I don't have to explain
to people how it is to be black and I
don't have to identify myself as black
and I don't have to represent the other
the other side of blackness I can just
be you just exist I can just be in exist
and I think that like what you just said
is so crazy that we are conditioned
because I bet you when that person said
that all of you guys are like okay well
let's think of something else that we
can get not the fact that know we all
want Sifu so you don't have to come it
was
oh no less change to make you feel
comfortable which goes back to what
Kelly said right we as black people and
I and I separate black people from
people of color because oftentimes
people of color separate themselves from
black people so we have to say those are
two different groups right people of
color and black people are trained to
always make white people feel
comfortable except for me
because what I told her was there's some
other stuff on the menu could eat let's
go yeah but that's how to retrain and
recondition your mind yeah so because
your natural instinct the way that we
were raised was to make white people
feel comfortable although stressful my
mother named me Megan Ashley wants to
job interviews they're like Megan Ashley
here yeah whoo oh yes no this very black
thick woman yes I'm Megan yeah hi nice
to meet you so good I'm so grateful for
this opportunity and that's you know
there's a phrase to they used to always
like bother me and like since way back
when is
when people would always tell me when we
talk about inclusiveness and kind of
understanding what other people come
from especially from an aesthetic
standpoint people who say I don't see
color and I'm like you shut you don't
you don't see [__] color shut the
[__] up I was a privilege to not see
color yeah I was like first of all that
doesn't even make sense and it's how I
look at mother after like it's already a
problem it's like in fact that you can't
look at somebody different and just say
oh that's cool you're different you have
a different culture but instead you say
oh I don't see anything we're all equal
for sentient beings David almost
literally which is why almost whatever
happened you know what I'm not gonna
contribute a black on black crime
let me tell you something this library
is open 24/7 365 and on a leap year 366
I'm always available for a good read but
I was like you know what let me back go
back up a little bit that's why that's
what I'm saying like I just that phrase
always always bothered me it wasn't
something that happened on later on in
life it's just I was younger yeah it's
like cuz you can't you're looking at me
you see I'm different
yeah knowledge it but echnology in a way
that makes it okay like I'm cool you
cool we are cold I was that weird kid to
where I remember just going to school
and my mom made this kimchi fried rice
right she's fighters fun so good but
then my dad stopped me I remember my dad
stopped me and I mentioned before on
this podcast my dad was like hey don't
take that to school because people will
look at you weird right and I was like
what do you mean he was like it smells
like people aren't gonna like the smell
and I was like that's cool and I just
took its cold you know and I ate it
right and I sat there and I remember
people were like oh what is that that's
weird and they were looking at my food
like it's weird
I ate it like it was perfectly fine but
I remember walking away feeling a little
odd that day and I was like why did my
dad say that oh my dad was kind of right
like they didn't look at me kind of
weird right but that's what I'm talking
about dad has been taught to dumb down
and water down his culture to make it
culturally acceptable exactly and so for
me as a young person because I wasn't I
wasn't really maybe I was just dumb or I
wasn't
Leigha where I just didn't give a [__]
it's like this this is if I have to look
at Karen's potato salad with raisins in
it Sam and that's and that's socially
acceptable at a potluck yeah look at her
potato salad wig shaved carrots and
raisins
each Oh kimchi fried rice bro yeah and
so you know it was so weird like looking
back at that now and I'm like wonder
what made me as a kid just go ahead and
take it as school and say I don't give a
[__] right like I didn't just enjoy this
but when people say that phrase I'm like
I was like oh I don't even see color
it's like yeah you do you do see it the
problem is is that you don't want to
accept knowledge acknowledge it and
accept it and that's what I have a
problem with you know and that's why it
goes back to now why people have issues
like Asian American or Asian restaurant
tours they have a problem with the white
person going like hey this is what your
food is is because used to make fun of
me for that and now that you say it's
okay now it's fine like that's why
there's that problem we don't get on
boxer braids how cultural appropriation
because I think there's multiple levels
of cultural appropriation right there's
the level of making it a costume or a
joke there's a level of alienating me
because of it and then there's the one
that I feel is feel like is the most
offensive is taking it and trying to say
that it is your own yeah that's that's
the biggest process well I've been
attacking a lot of these [__]
Korean artists on my Instagram it was
senior rap music's for everybody who
cares if it was started from black
people in Brooklyn you don't have to you
don't have to be a rapper to understand
or you don't have to agree with black
lives matter to be a rapper there are
two separate things just to be I'm gonna
[__] stab somebody just the beat wait
one day I'm just gonna stab somebody
because just having to go through that
conversation I'm just saying like hey
you just have to acknowledge that the
stuff that you're benefiting from like I
said somebody had to take those lemons
and turn it into lemonade and right now
you're drinking the lemonade without
acknowledging where that [__] came from
and it's offensive you should be a
prophet like lemon
you're taking your taking nobody took it
a step further - you're taking the
lemonade you didn't even have to deal
with the initial fight in the struggle
you're just reaping the benefits exactly
and that lemon is sour spot you have to
realize the ingenue even even something
like this and this is what I've always
said this is I used to put the shin and
stand up step back in the day but it's
like the dopest thing about black people
is is that no matter what black people
make oppression look cool hey Phil yet I
remember this girl he was in high school
bill says like seriously there was a
girl named Tanisha in high school right
- this girl she came to school one day
she were all over clothes inside out
right people looked at that and they
were like that shit's tight [__]
if I did that [__] people would threw
tomatoes at me you know I mean and what
I'm saying is like the dopest thing
about that is it's like I think and
people can acknowledge it and recognize
it like black Americans not even just in
the United States just globally are
movers of culture yeah whatever a black
person does first you already know that
somebody else is gonna try to swag a
historical because where was the Garden
of Eden located geographically speaking
right like the thing is is that black
civilization is civilization you cannot
have history without including the
teachings sick when I used to teach
sixth grade right the socialist book was
always so backwards and it was so hard
for kids to understand so I was like man
just because the publisher wrote it this
way doesn't mean I had to teach you this
way so I always would then start with
Kim it and ancient Nubia because then it
put into perspective everything else
right like how was Mesoamerica building
pyramids before Egyptians built pyramids
you can't have it right you have you
have to address it exactly in the
historical context and still looking at
that right even with because slavery was
more than just the stilling of of
Africans right and roots kind of points
this out I always say roots because
roots is what you know everybody had to
watch the scene with Kunta Kinte being
determined to keep his name is
because one we did not willingly come to
we had our own culture that cult in
order to try which is the same thing
they do in jail right in order to try
and get us to fall in line they had to
strip us no you're not Kunta Kinte
you're Toby because if I can strip you
from your name and I can strip you from
your at dignity Elijah then I win and so
we've always had to it was it was it's a
defense mechanism it's a survival skill
is using resiliency and oppression to
then empower us because we had to like
that was it was either that or die
yeah so even in the struggles like like
how you say your issue with the Korean
rappers which J you know like I told you
I love jay Park like jay Park is my
little boo I know he you know he
probably is 30 pounds lighter than me
and probably the same high but he's fine
and I love him so all of his music and
you know I mean I listened to HLT when I
was insane they're watching this and
they know me they already know yeah but
like they're not realizing that what
they seem
what they see is cool which is rap music
was birth out of oppression yes mm-hm
and poverty yeah wrap the the reason why
people beatbox is because they couldn't
afford instruments breath wanted to do
that with his mouth he couldn't afford
instruments he grew up in the in the
projects of New York that's all he had
you think he it turned out to be
something beautiful but it was born out
of struggle and the nacelle is so funny
somebody just comes in to dougie fresh
and like dude when you beat boss that
[__] is [__] dope it's I I want to do
this [__]
like rock you like the hell it's like
nah that shit's dope that's all right
ain't all this is necessity [__]
and that's the thing is that what other
people consider art is necessity right
like so much of black culture is built
off a necessity which is why people want
to take the black culture but they don't
want to be black yeah well you know what
the famous saying is everybody wants to
be black until it's time to be black you
have black children you need to be save
everywhere black lives matter everywhere
you're married to a black man with
mental health issues on the wrong day in
the wrong place
Kanye loves going to Wyoming step off
that reserve bruh you gonna get shot
yeah doing some of the foolish things
that you do which apparently was just
all a ploy Khalid said that he did it
you know to try send in this link and I
was like okay so you said it to Khalifa
leave send it to me yeah so I prayed
because I haven't listened to Kanye
Peter gonna help me there is killed so
Mia my best friend were like [__] me
so when I saw that and I was like I
could listen to his music again you know
cuz I was high I was like did he just
fall all of America just to get what he
had to get done for his people if that's
the case I'm only listening to Kanye
West for real is it even plausible like
that makes perfect sense
yeah that makes perfect sense but he had
to break himself down to assimilate to
get something done because that's what
we have to do that's what we have to do
that's what that's what it means to be
black everything and being a part of the
boys as talented tenth the whole concept
of the talented tenth was to say if you
make it out 10% you're responsible for
the other 90% you got to do it yeah
and that's a lot of burden right like
you didn't have to go to college to be
like dang once I go to college I have to
pay the way for all the other can be
Korean American boys in Sacramento yeah
that's what we got to do like Khalif at
whitney has to be
the role model for the all the other
black men that go to Whitney high school
cuz there's not that many so they don't
have that so all of that responsibility
is put back on him yeah
and Gary and to Johnny and dr. glass
because they're carrying the Bert and
that's for crazy dr. glass graduated in
Gary graduated in 2001 johnny graduated
in 2002 Khalif graduated in 2005 these
four men have to carry the burden of
other black males that come up come
after them that's how it is it be black
yeah and that's just sad because our
[__] walking lookin fly that's the hard
part too and that's that's just that
responsibility of trying to gain
generational wealth too it's not just
money at this point it's really giving
the leg up the knowledge everything
about this the giving them the leg up to
not [__] a shot out and shot in the
middle of a street there's so much
responsibility that like we talked about
it before on this podcast where somebody
at work found out not my work but
somebody they know at work found out
about their personal privilege just from
finding out from a co-worker about how
their children have been interact in
this world not through their own
personal experience but through the lens
of a parent and they found that common
ground it was like oh well did you did
you have to tell you did you tell your
kids recently about what he has to do
when he approaches a cop and how he
should behave so he doesn't die he goes
no I didn't he goes well I had to do
that for my kids oh my god that [__]
common ground is what it took for him to
be like oh [__] like I can kind of see
that he goes well they also have an
older child it's like well when I sent
my kid to college all I said to him was
hey don't drink too much
I didn't tell him like yo when you do
crazy stuff out in college and you walk
out in the middle of street or whether
were you wear a hoodie or not don't do
all that stuff because something could
happen do you know a my husband was sold
don't have a white girl in your dorm
alone that's crazy
have a good time in college like the
fact that these are conversations that
we have to say but I think it's even
more so the reason why it's exhausting
to be black is because one you have to
be black which means you have to deal
with
then too you have to educate others who
are coming into this new sense of
consciousness like oh my gosh I didn't
know that you were going through all
this you have to educate them and then
three you still have to operate as
spaces where you know people don't give
AF about you and you have to constantly
defend yourself constantly defend
yourself like the fact that in order to
get you to see my struggle I have to
reason with you on a parental level not
just a human being level yeah you don't
understand what is human a human but
when I bring in our kids then the whole
world falls apart the red sea parts your
eyes are open and you'll you're now Adam
and Eve in the Garden of anti-racism and
you see what racism is right yeah it's
like I mean that's what it is
right like it it just it baffles me that
we still have to have these
conversations and let's not get on white
fragility and guilt yeah because I also
don't need your apologies I just want
you to do better but like please I'm
tired of talking I don't want to keep
having to explain this to you like just
care donate and that's the other thing I
put up like oh you know we're trying to
raise money for yvs whatever whatever
right and I mean we have black we have
black excellence which is exhausting but
our whole black Alumni Association is
all black excellence right so we all we
put up our money when we went it was
time we were about that life but there's
not that many of us yeah so you know
like we had to ask for our allies I
posted this I'm telling you to help
donate to a student group at Whitney
high school do you know how many
comments I said all DME and explain to
me what's going on
children need money period
yeah why do I have to explain you the
oppression because guess what it's
talking about their oppression I have to
deal with my own but are they like you
though oh that's the other thing well
you know what they are because they went
to Whitney right oh you could come
inside now
Facebook is so [__] funny because I I
just go on Facebook you know
intermittently here and there and these
people these are people I know so when
I've liked your comedy page you better
be on there every day commenting and
responding back I have not hidden the
name so in that comedy page right so
originally before that before I found
about you know you know comedy fan pages
I just opened up my regular Facebook so
I like 5,000 friends they're not my
friends but I'm now only get to see
5,000 you don't know the line thousand
people impossible haha when I see these
five thousand people I get to see all
these people interact and that has been
one of the is this is a curse and a
blessing because these people who follow
me that like my comedy I have seen so
much anti-black like sentiment and
behavior it's unreal and a lot of it
came because a lot of my fan base is
Asian I'm reading it from you guys who
follow me that [__] with me and I'm like
how did this happen where where did this
happen where you follow me and you know
you think why do you like me like this
is the exact opposite of who I been
since day one so it's weird like for
example there was a girl in Asian girl
who put up on her things she goes she
wrote the thing that I always mentioned
it goes well my parents came to this
country they built the bah blah blah
blah blah why why can't black people do
the same same exact that's the operative
word came it was a choice exactly and so
just having to write that out I I didn't
have to do it people within their group
had to do it and so what they do is that
they see the people who are refuting
what she's saying using something very
simple as that
you you use the word came the adjective
came make it be you they came here by
choice they were given opportunity they
didn't have to fight for theirs this is
the biggest difference they'll ignore
that comment and they'll go to the
comment that already bolsters how they
feel and then go see you get it so it's
not people aren't in a position where
they want to learn they just want to
hear what they want to hear that's it
and this is this is easy it's just kind
of crazy lazy is just it's it's willful
ignorance you're just choosing to
continue to not do better but you live
in a society that makes it okay for you
to not do better I've only recently
started doing this thing now we're a man
I didn't know that I did this until a
friend mentioned it to me he goes you
know what I noticed that you do when
you're walking on a sidewalk and a white
person's come you refuse to get out the
way I only started doing a recently cuz
south pass he had a lot of nice white
people but he's like you specifically
I've seen Miss Lee make your presents
now yeah I don't know why I did it
but when I kind of look into it is
because I got tired of having to move
away for them it's like you're a person
I'm a person [__] you get out the
[__] way why do I always have to
[__] do it it was because I was like
subconsciously it's like oh here why
person I got to move out my way and so I
stopped doing that when I was like it
was like after college I was like I'm
not doing that [__] anymore [__] you
get out the [__] way unless you like
an older person or there's like more
people I'll do that but I don't know why
I had this inner urge to kind of just do
that for that and I need somebody tell
me you need to stop apologizing and
that's it's really that it's yeah
apologizing is no it is like oh I'm
sorry I'm in your way I'm sorry I'm
inconveniencing you I'm sorry my
presence is bothering you I'm sorry that
my existence is you know possibly
infringing upon your existence it's just
these little small things cause if it's
like an Asian person we play chicken
with it right if it's like a black
person Mexican person I play chicken
with it but for some reason for a white
person I would go oh I got to get out
the way and I'm like yo I don't know
when it clicked I stopped doing that I
was like I'm not doing that [__] anymore
it's more like I'm gonna do it based on
numbers it's like two people I'm one
I'll move out the way
but if it's one-on-one let's play
chicken you know and I'm fatter too so
you get the [__] out the way on the
bulldozer but I think for women I'm
about the way you better apologetic that
makes me think about that case last year
or that man was where that white office
off-duty officer shot that black man in
his own apartment when she thought it
was his and in that whole case you know
that right but the off-duty she was a
female officer white
she thought she's walking through her
apartment it was the wrong apartment was
a black man was living in there and she
did not and then she was like what what
were you here hung up these photos of
these black man do you not realise
that's not your house like does it smell
like man it's like it like police
training in that like we didn't engage
any of that so because you were on duty
just like the court case though he's
like his brother hugged her is that can
I hug her it was a black judge I
remember and it was like a mostly the
juror was mostly black and they were
like oh you know that the judge was
offering solutions as to how she can
move forward in life and then it's this
whole beautiful thing and then they I've
never in my life
walked into a place and was like this
maybes my own I know what the [__] my
house how many black suitcases do you
see on the thing at the airport but you
know specifically which black suitcases
is you exactly you know what I'm saying
like it's that kind of stuff where it's
like if I'm smart enough to know that
this black to me is mine and that black
to me is yours and we have nothing else
but just a black to me suitcase you can
know that this isn't your apartment
something inside of you should say you
know what maybe I don't know one of
these things is not like the other
especially just by smell I know what my
place smells like yeah right when I walk
in I smell I'm like this ain't my place
I'm out here yeah yeah gone just small
[__] I don't understand those situations
it's such a and I don't want people to
walk away from this podcast it's like oh
you're just [__] on Y people it's
not white people right it's not as
people it's people like it's it's it's a
white American ideal that we're talking
about right now you as an individual as
a white male as a white female you're
not being attacked right we're talking
about the construct in which your whole
life has been based on and all we're
asking right now is that you recognize
that [__] and correct that behavior
because you guys are gonna have children
and we're [__] tired we're tired of
you raising these children thinking that
it's okay and you're doing it whether
it's on purpose or not but it's gonna
take for you to recognize that for this
[__] to coins
Bridgette
they should to start and sustain that
because like just just the the man that
you just you know a good point it's just
they're gonna shift strategy yeah
there's gonna be a subliminal subliminal
pursuit to uphold and continue Oh white
declaration of independence yeah and you
have to recognize you have to stay on
top of your edge in it and in a coast
which podcast the statistics said that
seventy five percent of why people don't
have a single black friend they're only
aware of or why it's such an outrage
because their fellow white friend is
upset about it that's how they're
learning about it that's what that's
when that's when it affects them not
because that's other person who across
from your neighbors who's black is
hurting it's because your white friend
is curious and that's why for this is
why we talk about you know you got to
police your own people oh this is why
this is why it's [__] important
because I keep mentioning it's common
ground so if you're not gonna listen to
the other human being because they're
different in skin tone and Melanson
melanin content then you got to listen
to me that's why I'm saying police your
own people you have to talk to your own
community have these uncomfortable
conversations you can't just let it just
glaze over these uncomfortable
uncomfortable conversations causes
change it at least plants a seed right
you have to do this it's not because
your virtue signaling [__] all that
other [__] right get to your own people
and have that conversation right I have
to do it all the [__] time I know
it's a little easier for me because I'm
kind of an [__] but it took a while
it took practice for me to get to this
point right it's not easy it's not easy
for me to have this conversation with a
friend who calls me up in the middle of
night and say hey I want to be in the
middle because I see two sides to this
coin I go what's the two sides to the
coin and racism it's awkward and he gets
dead silent he goes oh that's not what
I'm saying okay that is what but that
may not be what you're what you think
you're saying but the intention behind
it is that yes I see why people are
racist and I see why racism is bad
either you agree with it would be racist
or you agree that racism is racism is
wrong but you can't see two sides to a
coin where this is a moral issue
exactly and that's just it's something
that simple and it's like you you want
to be in the middle because you want to
ignore these things that are happening
right now well guess what you have to
look at the state of the country and
what we're in you cannot ignore this any
longer so you are uncomfortable because
you have to make a choice a moral choice
and it [__] with your fragile ass sense
of comfort right because that's being
taken away from you right now you as an
Asian American man you want to be in the
middle of I want to be white person's
lap dog but at the same time I don't
want to be this other person so I'm just
gonna stay quiet
but now that people are asking you to
have an opinion you don't want to have
one so my question always is it's like
cool you want to be in the middle what's
your mission statement I don't have one
sorry buddy that you don't have anything
to stand on nothing there's nothing for
you to stand on I'm not telling you to
be angry as me I'm not telling you to be
as upset or be as verbose as I am but
what I'm saying is is that in a time
like this you can't be upset because now
you have to have an opinion that's not
have always had an opinion exactly it's
just you think outside of yourself and I
think that is where is that's where the
true problem lies is when we were
talking we were talking to earlier today
cliff and I were on a conference call
with the rest of the black Alumni
Association right and we were talking to
dr. Stephen glass who is just the king
amongst Kings right but he was
specifically talking about his
experience in mind you he graduated from
Whitney in 1986 I was born in 1985 so he
graduated from Whitney 34 years ago his
experience was they used to have Vasil
day right and vassal is a part of the
feudal system in middle in the Middle
Ages which is basically like slavery so
they used to have vassal day and you
used to bid on people at Whitney like
other things like you a bid on people
and they would basically have to do
whatever you wanted them to do so he
went home in the 80s and said this seems
like it's a problem right so they were
like oh you should talk to the principal
so he talked to the principal at the
time and the press well at the time was
irate a white man of course but very
irate talking to him as a freshman he's
a freshman now you know spit in
everywhere cuz he's mad and checking him
whatever whatever so he goes home tells
his mom momma glass wasn't playing those
games she went back to the school so the
next year when they don't have Bassel
day it's not because it's wrong right
it's because Stephen glass complained
and so now we don't get to have what we
used to have right
fast-forward to 2017 with the slave
experiment right a parent says I don't
know if I want my black son having to
endure the trauma of a sim you a slave
simulation right so she goes to the
department or she goes to the teacher
she's ignored goes to the department
she's ignored she goes to the
administration she's ignored she then is
like okay I'm going to have to talk to
somebody else so she talks to somebody
who then tells The Huffington Post who
then gets media attention involved so
then the experiment gets shut down right
this simulation gets shut down
it's not shut down because it's a moral
issue of right and wrong you get shut
down because this black mother who was
also then labeled a Fame [__]
she's a Fame [__] well as she went
through the proper channels to try and
advocate for other black children that
may be doing a slavery simulation is not
the best thing to do to get the point of
slavery across but it's not that we
don't have the slave simulation because
it's wrong it's we don't have the slave
simulation because this person
complained right and even that narrative
that black people having to advocate on
their behalf
or something that can be traumatic is
viewed as it's viewed as an
inconvenience to everyone else is a part
of the black experience right when we
were trying to come up with oh this is
crazy so in asking dr. glass I said dr.
glass can you know can we talk about
this story
he was like yeah but you also have to
tell them about the white Club and I was
like oh yeah we were just talking about
this white Club I was like oh yeah we're
just talking about this yesterday when
we went to go form club noir which was
founded in 2000 and kind of
unfortunately died out about like
2006-2007 because all of us that were a
part of the family of it had graduated
at that point when we were trying to
create it right we were then told well
then we should have a white Club now
there was a Korean American code there
was a Japanese American Club there was
Schatzi club there was club ties there
was all these other cultural clubs with
the moment we say hey we think we should
have a black cup then it's like well
then there has to be a white Club too so
they had a European history Club so we
say this right he was like wait what are
you talking about I said yeah well we
were found in club noir he said oh no I
was talking about in 1984 when we
created the essence club and we were
told then that there had to be a white
Club oh [__]
that's crazy right so I'm like wait you
you had to endure the same thing in 1984
with a lot of the same teachers that we
had in like 2000 and had to endured the
same thing I for sure we all thought he
was talking about what we were hearing
he's like what are you talking about
yeah he's like what are you talking
about talking about what I went through
so it's a it's a history of not just
ignoring not just underrepresented and
under black students and black voices
but making being making the black
experience and inconvenience to everyone
else and I say that because there would
be less complaints if you want to say
okay well when we just when we discuss
California history right we're gonna do
a Japanese internment camp simulation
and you know what when we talk about
world history we're going to do an
Auschwitz simulation right and then when
we talk about ancient or in Asian
civilization where you know let's do a
killing field the Cambodian killing
field simulation right no wouldn't
happen that wouldn't be a part of the
conversation I wouldn't it because
enough voices it wouldn't even take in a
voice it was just taking one person but
yet for the black experience it's an
inconvenient and see this is why I'm
also mentioning like how why I'm tired
of like the cyclical issue of people
just kind of using this as a PR thing
right it's like this is this is the
problem that's why I'm asking people
like don't I'm not telling you not to
post I'm not trying to police and tell
you how you should show your support
what I'm asking you to ask yourself why
if you do that this problem will stop
right because we've had this happen in
the last decade multiple times you think
George Floyd's incident is unique it's
not [__] unique it's not George Floyd
happened this is not even we're not even
enough room on a t-shirt to put all the
names if you wrote it in but I think
[Laughter]
I'll tell you I love King bass he's
actually a really good dude yeah he is a
good dude but okay man I gotta tell you
something black Twitter will [__] rip
that boy off they said it was like
you look like a Chipotle bag I cry when
they so hard
Jesus and then you know what's ahead of
you this one little tattoo but the time
this sucks it took five minutes I almost
passed out when he started doing the
curb on the L right all the name
come on come oh Jesus my keeping it real
goes wrong like at what point did your
you know he's like a walking kill monger
and I know he meant well my brother I
know you meant well the funny thing is
like what I saw Tamar rice I was like I
was like yo what is going on bro it's
like did you have a light go right that
[__] like that [__] would've been
hilarious
and the funny thing it was like I
couldn't stop laughing just said it with
his chest like literally when I saw how
red his chest was 86 tanks and within
those 86 takes nobody told them bro this
is a bad idea you know what this reminds
me of see this is the times when you
find out who your real friends are right
between the 86 fakes nobody telling him
that he was wrong was the same thing
when little Kim came out with that song
when she decided to have a patois accent
with all those people in the studio and
nobody so this was a bad idea you need
new friends you need new if kylie
jenner's friends were able to keep that
baby a secret do you hang out with them
because they keep it real
you know it was watching that baby why
don't you tell him because he didn't he
didn't confide in me
plus I'm gonna Asian the guy you like I
know I don't have a say in this [__] and
so like when I was watching it right and
and it took me about 36 times just to
watch it all the way through let it do
the part you gonna learn today so crazy
that was a point where I was watching
this [__] right and I was like okay I
like King bash because he has a young
audience and there's a young so there's
a young audience and a lot of white
people that fall that people need to
hear this stuff right but the moment he
came on and I was like oh he's doing
spoken word I was like okay spoken word
is a very difficult thing to tackle
let's see if he could do that and then
he wrote [__] a brand deal I was like
first of all [__] that's the
most best what you need though that's
like the most socially distance thing
I've ever heard of because what didn't
the [__] are you talking about right now
like people understand your plight of
not taking a brand you love a million
dollars like come on bro like batch I
Love You Man but somebody in your circle
should have told you people can't relate
to that [__] dude hey and then he said
this I've never heard a black male ever
say this in my life he said kick rocks
tik-tok kick kick rocks I was like bro
that is the weakest line I've ever heard
of my life
and I want to tell you something man I
love you like I appreciate you so
[__] much what you've done for social
media people and this platform and
saying what you had to say but when your
chest turned bright cherry red you
didn't take a break in between takes to
let that inflammation calm down I wanted
to ask him like so one of his other
friends tonight was thinning a group
thread you know like it was like look at
this I'm not gonna say the word but look
at me get Cleveland or he got locked out
no let me refill my wine
well I mean what I'm talking about the
whole batch situation is because I'm
only I'm also talking about just like
social media people are celebrities who
feel like they have to say something let
me tell you something about that
celebrity [__] video while I
appreciate you forsaking it for whatever
reason first of all I want to see the
receipts right because I want to know
the brand that said hey if you support
your culture you will not get this check
do you see what I'm saying it's like
that's an example of like just a little
bit just a little and I want to like I
said I'm not [__] on the dude like
I'm his biggest [__] supporter but
because I'm your big supporter supporter
doesn't mean that you can't hold them
accountable like grab words mean things
if you support black people we're not
giving you a million dollars
yeah nobody said no exactly the KKK my
who was it who is your brand support who
said hey there was another girl named
Leanne who I actually very much liked to
write and she did a version of what
batch did but what she did was she did a
stop-motion thing where she wrote like
BLM and then she was doing - what's
wrong with the world mama people watch
this
yeah she she's black necessarily part
just like just watching that [__] and
she got roasted so hard because of that
it's like you didn't watch batch of [__]
and you as a Filipino woman thought you
were gonna get away with it you have any
idea I know for a fact because that will
stop motion and you had to do every
single letter [__] that took you six
days you did a six day mistake I think
what people forget is because the
dragging that went on like I couldn't
even make it the reason I couldn't even
make it through the whole video was
because you're on tik-tok with kick
rocks threads in the comments like
Vasiliy that's what black twitter truly
exists for it's not necessarily the
original post
it's the comment yeah man I literally
told Khalif well looking at that video
it looked like that [__] fell
asleep on a pile of newspapers you know
this whole video is just going to be
called
roasted king bed no I mean he he meant
well see as a teacher I'm always able to
try and validate people's actions yeah
because I had to understand what 10
year-olds think so he meant well you
know pray for let's just keep him in art
let's keep him lifted in prayer yeah
okay I don't know how he's gonna recover
from this it's so weird just watching
just watching that [__] and I'm like
people understands like man you roast
people a lot it's like cuz I had to I
grew up in a black community so if I
didn't come quick with it I would have
just been the loser in the group you
want to tell the people what I said
about you that David is a black a 40
year old black woman that had his prime
in the 90s walking around with like you
have to drown the waterfall the
waterfalls you have the swoop bank and a
French roll that is your prime you
talking about literally you talk about
like literally half the customer base
and my parents are when I was growing up
to be I love
of 90s black women it was funny because
I was telling her about how like I like
eavesdropping on my fiancee teachers
like that is the most black woman
favorite you could ever do I'm saving
all the stares listening to I am do you
see the phone I'm not talking to you who
is that nobody for you that's [__] me
like what Mario's on the phone if I'm uh
who's that I guess I'm up don't be on
speakerphone cuz you start throwing it's
you since the first girls I'm on speaker
for you hey I'm trying to breastfeed be
quiet
bear hugs respond she goes why do you
care you don't even know if they know
you maybe they know I got infiltrated as
a young kid I don't even know these type
of behaviors have a drag queen living
inside of me where I definitely do honey
I mean we all have a little bit of
schizophrenia in is just like I believe
everybody is somewhere on the autism
spectrum that's why it's a spectrum
people aren't weird AF which is another
reason why they should have left Elijah
alone is because I'm not getting you
yesterday yesterday my husband and I we
were going to eat and this is not a flex
but I had to say it so you get the
contact so we were going to eat a South
Coast Plaza so we're eating and we're
walking across like the bridge from
crystal court and it was hot yesterday
I'm not kidding you this man literally
look like he just got off the ski slopes
in bail like hats like the Patagonia
like puff jacket the like ski I mean I
don't ski but the ski pants we're like
boots okay newspaper with a mask and I
was like you know what honey it's time
for us to go because nobody
nobody else's alarm that this man is in
the middle of Costa Mesa looking like
he's just got off as misty list in the
middle of June and nobody else is a
nobody else is questioning this you know
what I should have done I should have
called the police
I really should I was concerned there
are so many I could tell you so many
weird stories just about my parents
store and like a customer fit like I'll
tell you like the people who steal [__]
they always still the most oddest things
even noticed dude that came into our
store while I was still a Maurice crease
was behind the counter because everybody
steal that [__] yeah so they really did
y'all did really do own a black beauties
applause tell you this right now and I
never understood like a for a fact I
read I already knew this would happen
because if you guys don't know what
Maurice Greece is that should stick as
look if that [__] ran out it was only
because 17 of your family members were
using the same or you lost it
are you lost I told you I bought my
husband one ten years ago still using
that same that same Murray's index it
has just even thicker than Dax is mad
earlier I used to just [__] open it I
just like the smell
specifically like I smell attacks -
smells great this one who once came in I
remember it was like [__] when people
bring the grease back and they would
just [__] pick a little chunk out if
they knew that will last in six years
that she was 329 it's not even that
expensive like just [__] no that's
not gonna happen because I would always
have to open it up and well you wouldn't
let them take it back oh they go digging
I'm like no look at this it was like
that one else I know is that because I
sniff these cans I open up every single
one and I sniffles not a nose
indentation then it's not so you [__]
you know they they make it like like the
hook it's the hook that means you shared
this
about 7:00 p.m. I be [__] lying to me
about this [__] I got traumatized
because that stored because all the
stupidity had a deal with my dad's
Khalif in like I've known Callie for
over 20 years right I feel like only one
29th of the time has he ever had like a
fade I never had a fade right yeah I
didn't I had no idea a break that leaves
here it's right there yeah he was like
you need for plan babe you need a fan
what phase it differ from a Barbara's
label from a regular head yeah I used to
but I know you did because my so my
parents store originally was next to a
hair stylist place so before that dude
Lord Tony would you jail I'm sorry what
was this Joe Joe shoutouts to Lord
Tony's artistic fingers Tony's artistic
fingers because he used to do nails
right Lord
Tony's artistic imagine okay let me just
ask you what do you think he looks like
well looking at that now I figure that
he's probably short dark skin may or may
not have long hair that's debt like laid
to the gods he's wearing a faux Versace
shirt and walking around here like
excuse you and also in the same in the
same sentence what he would say I excuse
you well light you up with the block so
let me tell you this right accurate Lord
Tony's are very similar he used to wear
velour [__] all the time
yeah he's Katt Williams so he he is cat
wounds velour [__] I'll be the same
velour type of like suits jumpsuits
whatever you could think of Crocs on his
feet slicked back raucous Crocs on his
feet 24/7 Crocs on his feet slicked back
hair everything the nicest [__] man
I've ever met in my life but he went to
jail for some [__] I don't know what it
was but during that time he went for
jail his name is Laura Tony Moore tone
I think we can all infer that's why he
went to jail but he got out he opened up
another nail shop but yeah I'm lucky
when I get my nails I mean he's a such a
nice dude I don't know what he went to
jail for but I loved he used to treat me
super well him maybe I don't want to
think about the Lord Tony like that but
we're sorry Lord Tony
yeah but I need to get my hair cut also
my blonde used to cut my hair but when I
did want to get her cut from her I used
to go to this spot across the street and
they used to pay people up your parents
are accidentally blew the blackest thing
my mama used to cut my hair but then
when I didn't feel like and so I used to
get it across the street and then when I
was like I had to make my own money I
was super broke I stopped getting Barbra
haircuts and I just went to the Asian
spot because they would just do it fast
but I used to hate those [__]
haircuts but then that's when I learned
how different a [__] fade was versus
just getting like this is a LAN military
ass cut but you know barber cuts are
[__] expensive because it takes a
time with it it makes sense that you
gotta art it is a fire yeah okay I gotta
say Thank You Man he said you need like
a line up I was like what I was just
like just save it I feel like I felt him
oh you know what cuz remember you took
me to get my hair shaved I just shaved
it off member I was right across from
this through his mom oh yeah yeah I also
have some whiskey store yeah at the
train tracks I wasn't sure if you were
sure
yeah but you know what though it's
because it's like you know black men
don't just shave their heads right but
clearly Khalif did it no strands were
harmed right
like no hair follicles like he was
straight but I never thought about that
yeah man I wrote this joke back in the
day that for sure will not last just
because of the times but cuz I forget
sometimes I'm an Asian man yeah yeah so
you guys know Tosh it's a slave weight
so I was glad it was it wasn't the
golden glow' it was it was a it was the
Oscars right and yeah who's the main
actor in 12 years a slave I love you
tell ultra4
so he goes up and it was being my best
friend it wasn't just me and I literally
looked at him and he had he still had
his 12 years of slave hair right and I
was like this [__] is 12 year I just
wrote ice cream captain I wrote 12 years
no fade yeah and I gotta tell you that
she would not it would not age as well
now no but you gotta [__] 22 oh yeah he
look like a broken cookies my yeah
actually I feel like that joke would be
on par always because there's one thing
like so being that was like it was crazy
my parents were divorced right I didn't
grow up with a black male in the house
Yeah right
and my grandpa my dad Paul would give us
money suggest I would just lather Dax
and marie's in his hair and then cut it
with scissors I don't know what like my
grandfather just really loved us because
it would be a mess he would give me $20
to make a mess of it right well when I
got when Hunter and I before we got
married we shacked we live in we lived
in sin sorry
family he was so like he routinely got
his hair cut every week right and it was
just little things like the line of hey
like dang man Katy pushed me back a
little bit and I was like can you
enlighten me on what pushed me back cuz
he's like here's my natural hairline he
pushed it back but if you push it back
enough like it won't grow back I was
like okay then he told me about the line
he was like you don't want the harsh
line in the back of your neck you wanted
to be like you baited up so now I feel
like I am a haircut line up connoisseur
so as a connoisseur I would say that I
feel like that would still be
appropriate and I think you can
definitely because I feel like as
there's like certain things as black
people that you have to have done at all
times one is your hair for black woman
is your hair in your nails right nothing
else is done i'ma tell you something I
have been quarantined like for real for
real but
soon as I was in San Diego right and I
was like I need to look up a nail salon
that I'm gonna play a pretty penny for
so I don't get kovat
but these nails have to get done right
so I did it and I asked my husband I was
like babe you don't get your lineup done
but my husband is like super cold with
like the Clippers and stuff now yeah but
with talking to my other male black
friends they were like yeah I got that
appointment for Saturday more like it's
just something that has to be done so
the fact that he would go on national
television and not have a proper lineup
like blood it was insane this is a KD in
the middle of the finals come in the
moon right now Kevin Durant his mind I
mean he his hair that no it is a stray
dog I say hello like Jamal Murray's
crotch pubic hair the way is balled up
very nice person but it's like Braille
you make this is what black people
always say when your hair like looking
at old boy with no line up there like
you make so much money for that
like at some point where like you're
gonna state I'm like if I don't if I
don't get like my hair right now I'm
about to get a haircut in a couple days
right I'm about to get my [__] like cut
my fate in lined up the only reason why
it's like this now is because I'm trying
to stretch my dollar you know I mean
it's not because I'm not a parent that I
need one it's just that if I want it to
look nice I got to get it done every two
weeks maybe that's cuz you're trying to
retire fade you I've seen like people
with like bait like a friend of mine
gets his hair cut every week I guess I
shoulda cleaned up Chris but that's why
like you have to learn like after you
get it fade I was telling him like
unless you're gonna do it yourself it's
gonna cost you six seven bucks to get
your [__] lined up every every week just
because it starts to grow out it's not
crisp and clean anymore but you only
have about a two and a half weekly wait
with it then you got to get it done
again yeah exactly
dang I forgot I took you to get I was
like are you sure you want to get your
hair shaved yeah it's like yeah I'm just
tired of having all the hair and I think
it's because I mean once again
a black identity like your ID like
people began to identify you more by
your hair then actually getting to know
you which is kind of crazy yeah but is
it true like that really became no I was
just the de giraffe in the hallways with
afro Defra so you had an afro since high
school this is back in the day we're
talking when he was in seventh grade no
facial hair just tall light-skinned with
the fro I remember I used to wear a
stocking cap under my baseball hat
you did I had to do it and I know it's
for wigs I know that the [__] but it is
more than a stocking cap even with your
hair poking through it no you didn't
would you slay it flat lay it flat
yeah it did it would you play a flat I
need to see proof so it would just let
you know like Friar Tuck like in the mid
we shared and I should be like I never
did like and I never did it for the wave
but we had it at the store and I was
like I like the way let's put it pokes
out the Hat so we got that little color
on it that's all I should have never
shared this you know [__] this fine you
know what you should talk to you should
talk to Patrick about our trip to this
awesome spot me oh I gotta ask him about
that [__] there's so many stuff there's
so many stories that edrick had to tell
Eric has to say on this podcast is
unreal so they decided to we had when I
mean Whitney's talent show sorry
Whitney's talent show was like really a
big deal because we had it in Knott's
Berry Farm and they decided i haven't--
think of what was the club they created
a club like I was like a rapper and it
was Jeff shoutout suggestion Jeff Shum
now his bike Jeff can you
it's the rut yeah can you just I just I
just want to talk to Beyonce so they
were doing this performance right this
was 2003 mm-hmm so you cannot do a rap
performance in not have a velour suit
okay
however cerritos mall
they weren't stocking the horses like
that demo was it demo was not either
demo wasn't even it's a real small bit I
don't even know demo are up in the up
against the wall I don't even think they
weren't in Lake Molly liquid yet right
so I was like okay well I'll take you
guys so this lawsuit says oh and you
found him a velour suit oh all of them
and actually I will stand by this those
were some of the Flies like they looked
hella fly like they were up there like
wrapping with the Vallauris to saw it
was for 2003 because you also have to
remember it my senior picture I had
twist waterfalls a flip and a swoop bang
so this was 2003 was all or nothing they
straight and just stick to like a tool
you had all of them and what a classy
because I had a baby fat peasant blouse
on oh my god oh yes oh yeah see the
thing is I have to I have I have to be
committed to it if not I'm going to cry
and lay on the floor because I committed
so many fashion offences but it was
fashion at the time so they were help
they were extra fly like baggy and all
just women in a sea of velour that's
they just dress up like Lord Tony just
one day find that video these crazy kind
of Sacramento if I want to get a velour
suit I know exactly where to go where
you go this is it's a spot out and on
foreign road I don't know what the name
is anymore but it always flips out
because it used to be a part of a store
in floor and mall which got tore down
because a lot of like gang [__] or
whatever but there's always a spot if
you go on forum road there will always
be at least a couple stores that only
sell long Harvey Steve Harvey suits and
velour suits there is always gonna be a
market for that
I don't know [__] why as long as you
there comes in there comes the age it's
so bright a passage right like Simba you
know fast the circum the price since
Whitney likes to think that black
culture is is similar to Lion King right
there's a point in age
I would say it's around like 42 where
you trade where you transition into what
we call a black daddy you go from the
daddy to a daddy or a black uncle right
you know mandatory that you trade in
your slim suits for your three-piece
baggy suits that you trade in your
Ferragamo for Stacy Adams and that you
trade in your track suits for linen
suits or oversized velour suits this
also one tells you going to the Playboy
Jazz Festival you may or may just brunch
at spaghettini z-- if you're in
California you have to go to the wave
live jazz brunch on Sundays at Spago
teenys and every other year you do have
to go on a cruise and it's just
mandatory so there's always a market for
that because black men if they're
allowed to be alive you know cuz the
police don't kill him they are going to
turn 40 to you I know for a fact my best
friend is gonna be that uncle he's he's
already almost there as he say I mean
when hundred I first started dating like
he was like 23 looking like a black
daddy I was like just because he have a
man bruh like we had to reel it back but
I know it's coming like my father-in-law
is the quintessential black daddy let me
say something we went to a funeral we
had a family member died so we were at
the repast my father I'm not kidding you
had on his straw hat gray fedora his
black dry-fit polo that said Hennessy on
it I'm not a [__] funny I'm not
exaggerating his gray loafers that
matched his grey shorts that had the
crease down the front right so young cat
decided to challenge him in dominoes and
then was surprised he lost and I said do
you see what this man is wearing sip by
Hennessy written across his left chest
should let you know right you don't want
this bones game you were about to lose
just like you never want to play spades
with somebody who's sitting there
with a toothpick in their mouth yes it
pulls the cards out from their back
you've got a little is that the repast
know what the funny thing is is like the
way you describe your father-in-law is
exactly how my dad dresses right now
like he but instead because he tell you
earlier that you guys are accidentally
Korean so my dad he has the slack with
the creases but obviously because he
works at the beauty supply store he has
a lot of free swag but instead the
Hennessey polo he got the African pride
hope the polo African pride dr. miracle
bug and polo on yes dr. miracle and it's
and it's the the African pride [__]
polo right with the African flag colors
[Laughter]
so because we would get all this like
promo stuff from all these black
companies right you know my notebooks in
school right we're all from African
pride just for me just for me notebooks
I had all this other [__] from the store
calendars pens pencils it was all from
every [__] black product you could
think of
I had a [__] I had a [__] calendar
from s-curl but I used to have on my
desk and now we just have to mark my
days on that [__] so all my stuff was
from my black companies all the time all
my notebooks it was free like little
Korean American students pulled out it
just for me no booking we were broke it
was paper oh we had a smiley girl on the
front of this plane oh man I had this
when I wasn't - you don't understand
just for me with like just for me for a
little blonde girl the 90s was like what
covergirl is for mm-hmm
I was like hey it's a white box simple
curl was just so perfect and she had the
pink balls yeah the knockers right
he was what we like to call default
brown like she was default Brown so that
every every little black girl casino
sells I was like hey I want that [__]
like that with like neon green pink
yellow and all those other colors right
switched over to a light pink box later
on and it just goes back and forth with
that but it was always made for like
young black girls it was just a gap grab
their [__] I always grabbed it oh for
sure it grabbed it especially when you
open up Essence magazine and it was not
for Easter maybe don't be Easter Sunday
honey because I was like I want this but
I don't want I would like I don't want
the pink click clacks I want the clear
one so it matches with my Easter outfit
and my mom would be like you're wearing
a bow tie don't want to wear a bow just
for me girl in a Jet magazine do I
remember just every every week so we
would go to the the the swap meet
so we could grab you know large supplies
of knockers right so we would always
have to go there like a.m. in the
morning class knockers yeah so we would
get a bunch of those and so everything
balls yeah so we would come in and then
we will buy a whole bunch of them and
obviously we saw them 99 cents if we
really like the customer it'll just be a
dollar no tax we got a bunch Oh actually
whatever you need I'm going back to
Sacramento uh real soon I think in about
a couple weeks so if you have you seen
my daughter's hair it is yeah whatever
you need let me know I'll get it and
then I mean she has beautiful hair but
it's just it's least contingent is the
point of convention between us and I
always say they should do murdering her
and I'm just trying to make sure her
curls are the funniest thing is like the
company that's still around there's a
few companies that's been around since
before I was born that's still [__]
going on now so for eight that
[__] company is wrong I just
react on Sulphur eight the braid spray
that [__] like yesterday I bought three
bottles hey that thing let me tell you
something sulfur eight you know what
we're in the day and age where you judge
packaging sulfur a literally has had the
same packaging since its existence oh
you want
always buy it you want talk about saying
that blue magic Oh blue madness with no
seventies I was waiting cuz I've been
seeing like African probably did a great
job in rebranding right there
specifically because of companies like
dr. miracle that came in and they were
having that the high-end black black
beauty products they kind of changed the
game a lot I did they did they changed
the block because they were going after
a lot of these other companies like soul
for eight right but they were doing what
those products do but just in a better
way and then we're selling it up for a
higher price
yeah but the thing is though and I will
say this as a black hair care
connoisseur I feel like a lot of these
black hair care companies try to
assimilate to packaging that they felt
would be appropriate because they were
trying to get it at Target right but
like companies like Silver Age so for
eight they know their niche like I can't
find sulfur eight at Target so where do
I go I either have to go to the beauty
supply store because not in Cerritos or
I order it on Amazon which I did
yesterday and I ordered I'm not kidding
you order four bottles of it right and I
think he goes back to speaking like
black hair care is set black hair care
is a billion dollar industry right like
if I just think about it myself
hunters kind of grown his hair out he
has his own set of hair products I have
my own set of hair products McKenna has
her own set of hair products devon has
its own set of hair products I probably
have enough hair products to open up a
beauty supply store on my own and a lot
of these products just sit because you
try it out and it doesn't work and so
that's how I thought about dr. Miracle's
right when they did this home rebranding
I feel like African probably did better
because they kept like the African pride
the scalp oil formula stay the same dr.
Miracle's they changed it up dr.
Miracle's I gotta be on me and so even
though the packaging is pretty I was
like oh you guys change it up because
you guys want white people to buy you so
this doesn't work for black it doesn't
work for textured hair yeah which I get
but it's like I appreciate it so for
eight keeping that same you know you
either have the little light blue
packaging or the bright yellow packaging
you got the what I sprayed it in my hair
before I came I sprayed my hair with the
sulfur eight
scalp conditioning for braids locks and
twist pray and I slicked down my edges
with the edge style spray or the edge
style
I just like my edges down for you this
is not a corner slick for you honey and
for the people cuz I'm not trying to
have anybody in the comments light look
at me I know can't see that you call me
a ho but you know it's funny cuz I
already knew like the the customers who
had a little more money they would
always go for the motions products kind
of died out yeah I mean they were come a
come-up mazzani really mazzani is a
match during a while so I want to know
Johnny is a miracle milk yep Pazhani has
a come up because mazzani has really
mazzani has become the black equivalent
of like paul mitchell especially more
hair colored my hair in my hair super
blonde I mean you could kind of seen in
the braids but I'll show you off camera
but it's like super blond and so they
partner really well like my cousin she's
a really great hair stylist she is in
the Union and stuff so she works on sets
of things but she still has her own
salon suite and so she used this
literally Redken for color and then
mazzani afterwards with maybe a olaplex
so mazzani has really stepped up their
their haircare game but stayed tried and
true to the black hair care market
they've stayed true to their demographic
while stepping up the quality of their
product that's it that's interesting I
haven't been in the store in a hot
minute
so everything I know is like super dated
now that I didn't even know that oh no
all the brands that you still mentioned
are still popping still there's still a
market for them you know what I have
seen them
I should always cracks me up when I see
like an old cat and I look at his hair
and as his hair is so [__] black that
if you put a spotlight on it it would
absorb everything Beijing vegan vegan
but black people pronounce a baby Sheen
what's the strike you get baleen
from cuz i ge is because it's Chinese
it's so like I would always correct
every customer be like can I get that
Beijing begin and they're like yeah
begin but I will see I wouldn't crack
[__] up because if you guys don't know
there's a couple of different blacks you
don't just get a regular black right
there no one there's a one B so there's
jet black and this regularly when I go
black
I go jet black or 1b yeah so number one
is jet black 1b is vegan baking it's is
this if you guys look up this thing like
on the internet of a black paint that it
just absorbs all light that's what black
when he despised atoms when he does
because the thing about vegan slash
Beijing I just have to say Beijing yeah
the thing about it is that they really
try to act like we don't know this isn't
natural but you got this dude that I
just do that like I kind of used to date
back in the day sorry babe part of the
reason why I couldn't ever take him
seriously was because I was like dude I
see where your babies just rip it's just
perfect because it's like perfectly like
there's no hair follicles or anything is
just like it's it it's so and well now
get on the hairline and it's so it's so
unnaturally talk it it's as pure black
as it [__] gets like I can't trust
you like if you're trying to lie to me
about your hairline what else are you
lying about bro you get this [__]
darkness and stuff that what's the name
down NBA player probably he probably use
B and you what the thing about Chicago I
knew it the Lakers yeah we're talking
about nobody like when he started this
away Britt yes so so the reason why
people like begin a lot to is a natural
product right so it's it is it's Asian
base so that's like it's like a powder
that you mix with water and it doesn't
have chemicals in it so it's really good
for your hair but it feels it feels very
unnatural when do you see it painted on
like that [__] is darkest like people
aren't using it the way that it was
intended to be used its I'm sure that
they were try but it's supposed to like
tint your hair if you have hair but the
way that they're using it is to create
painted head into this so it's just
glistening on your scalp she's like I
know your hairline is receding
but you're vegan benzene it's like right
here but I see yeah I see the gap
because all and you have to get somebody
else to apply that [__] for you to
because it drips a lot so if you're
doing in a barber shop yeah she's not
easy to apply cuz it drips everywhere
because you have to mix it with water
and so once it gets on your skin it's
hot you're [__] scared I was a
project manager for an entertainment
firm so whenever we would have clients
that had to you know come out here for
like do shows or whatnot
I literally had they would be like hey
do you know a barber who does that
Beijing Beijing testa for you know for
camera and like so you don't go on
national TV with everybody knowing that
that's tiny piece of black on the hair
that should look like fresh asphalt dude
that's exactly what it looks like okay
but people really like they weren't
really committed to it like to this day
to this day to this [__] day cuz I
just remember every single product that
I knew that customers really liked right
and I made it as a point because I
worked at the store so much and it got
to the point where I'll I'll see you
about taking it over at the store
because I wanted to I wanted to like
really know about these products like
what works and what didn't because
people would come in and they would get
mad that it didn't work I'm like quit
buying the same [__] [__] yeah I mean
like you saw that commercial on whatever
I don't know where the [__] you saw it
and you got it was gonna work and it
doesn't work go for the stuff that's
been around for a long time so for eight
always [__] work yeah but the thing
is and and it and it goes back to like
natural hair right is that even within
natural hair like you know they're like
oh there's different types of hair
textures they're still porosity that's a
part of it too
right like my hair I would be consider
like a 3 C of 4a
yeah the porosity level like I have very
low porosity so or I'm sorry I have very
high porosity so my hair will suck up
moisture but it will also release it
very fast right yeah McKenna is probably
like a 3 C we have the same hair texture
but she's low porosity so we can't use
the same hair products and I think that
like a lot of people don't
have that same experience worse like
they can go in there they're like oh I
want to get Carney a frooties yeah we
can't do that like there's a lot of like
that's the thing too that people have to
realize I definitely wanted when you buy
chemical products no matter what it is
whether there's skin care hair care you
have to realize that there isn't a blank
thing that works for everybody you have
to try it and give it a go and if it
doesn't work it doesn't [__] work
that's why I always say if they're
looking for a new products go for the
smaller bottle yeah I don't know what's
gonna happen so try it out first and
then don't blame the company for being
it's just not right for your hair you
just got to figure it out that's like
that balance so that's why I always ask
customers like why did you think this
worked like why did you like this so
much right and even something small to
like I remember those dude they used to
always come in for bumpstop or two all
the time [__] had the craziest
razor ball today
I remember the what was that called skin
skin something there was bum stopper
there was another one there was those
two companies that were killing it
mm-hmm and it was only bump stopper and
then when bum stopper 2 came out it was
like a stronger formula but there's a
dude that used to always get crazy ass
razor bumps and ingrown hairs because he
would he just never knew how to shave
his [__] hair and he was like this
bum stop or [__] never works
I'm like bro right you don't worry
sounds like you don't understand it's
your hair type you know I mean like
black men have curl coiled hair so
number one if you shave against the
grain it's already gonna [__] up a
little bit but you can do depending on
how it grows out but bum stopper is only
an aftershave it's not gonna prevent the
way you have to have a sharp blade right
and they would use these dull [__]
blades every time and I'm like yo what
blade do you use and I'm just using the
regular [__] you better have to teach
black man you would irritate me like man
David is this blade sharp enough before
I shave myself cut you're like a man you
good yes so what I would tell him is
this it's like yo you don't want you get
your [__] lined up right you get a fade
right usually get your [__]
your beard done right yeah do you walk
away with razor bumps like no you know
why cuz I should've sharpest [__] you
know it so because your hair is a little
thicker you can't you can't use that
blade like five or six times is still
think that it's okay usually if thicker
hair you have to throw it away a little
faster you just gotta use like my
husband he shaves this hair he cuts his
beer with clippers right that's another
way to me Tristan walk
has to think about it is that like you
we have a lot of black people that have
made quality black products that
specifically are geared for our
community like would bevel right mmm
bevel not only is amazing because of the
razors but just like the Clippers like
the wireless Clippers itself right black
me I can't use shaking really like like
they can't use that right it has to be
clippers so like Tristan Walker has
carved out his own space in this
industry to create a product that is
geared specifically towards black people
but I mean that goes back to the
divisive nessus because it cost a pretty
penny but guess why because you're
getting quality you also there wireless
Clippers you charge them you take it off
it gives you the same benefit in the
same satisfaction as like a Schick or a
Gillette razor dude but it's not gonna
give me razor bumps oh do you want razor
bumps or do you want do these Andes
Clippers were so [__] powerful like I
remember my mom used to give me her cuz
with these Handy's Clippers that we had
at the store it was so [__] power
that she would rock my dome cuz it would
vibrate so much it has to be strong
because it's for black hair yeah right
cuz it has to go through all this yeah
for me I don't got black hair but I
remember my mom with my dam is just so
powerful it tickles it would make me
giggle and so because I would move a lot
in my mom has a short temper I used to
hate getting haircuts from her because
when she would cut my hair I'm ticklish
I would flinch it but she was slapped me
upside my head so [__] much it was
just stop moving boom upside the head
stop moving boom upside the head all the
[__] time my childhood traumas coming
out right now no but you know what
though that brings me back to the
episode that you did with keV when you
guys were talking about how your parents
parented right specifically with not
having patients I think that goes back
to is not just that your mom was short
patient but your mom was in a foreign
country she didn't know the language she
was trying to make a living so she
didn't have time for you to be taking
time to be again you know like I think
as we get older we realize that our
parents are people mm-hmm so you begin
to understand some of the decisions that
they made specifically if it's like yeah
I'm trying to be a kid but my mom
have time for me too because she had to
go back to the store so that she can
make a living so that she could provide
for us and make the living here in this
foreign land I had a conversation with
my mom yesterday and we were talking
like I was telling her how my fiancee
Muriel I was like she's so unreasonable
like when I wake up she always has
something to say to me and she goes
that's just how women are let me tell
you what I did to your dad yesterday
your dad we were supposed to wake up go
to work he was on the computer he was
supposed to clean up the dog stuff and
man and then clean the floors and I
yelled at him right when we woke up and
I looked at I was like that's still not
okay
just because you do it doesn't mean it's
okay but how old are your parents
my mom's 67 I think 67 68 and my dad's
62 mama so be in cover a young cat I
know that cradle-robber this what we
call her she's not a cradle-robber she
was she knew what she needed honey your
daddy liked it liked it I could tell you
about some drama my face like this but
right when you think so you're 33 mm-hmm
trying to retire yeah by 35 your parents
are in their 60s still going to work I
know so your mom is probably like dang
Papa so my you need to get up so we
could hurry up and get to the store
because I'm trying to hurry up and get
back home so you need to get up and do
this stuff my mama which doesn't make it
right but I'm just trying to I don't
know that's over here trying to defend
Muriel like it's okay for her to yell at
you to do stuff I was like see you're a
problem I'm like my dad's cracking up
and you forget your mom raised you like
no you need to be yelled at right true I
do it a little bit I just don't want to
be woken up to that [__] like I open my
[__] eyes and it's like let me tell
you what you did wrong I might jump out
this [__] window right now will harm
myself before it's the air listen I will
literally jump out this [__] window
how dare you I hate that [__] I hate
waking up and then figuring out what
I'll [__] up on it's like I was just
born today
she has a ass-whooping on layaway let me
go back cuz you know what that means
that means she fell asleep like just
wait till morning she knows she dreams
that like I dream of my to-do list and
stuff in my sleep
Oh wake up him I'm like gotta go gotta
do this and I was like hey baby
just stay chill I'm like no no I got to
do that he's like that can wait I'm like
she didn't grow up with like a lot of
like I don't think like too much my
house was crazy you know so she huh
she's not used to I'm entertained by
what you share on the pocket here's your
upbringing but I can't relate my house
was [__] crazy just going back and
just real there's this time to I don't
know if I even show this on the podcast
so I mean sharing it now yeah sure yeah
I don't know if this is your warning
yeah just like I said so you know what's
that what's that one movie with jet was
it Jack Nicholson or he [__] takes
the ax and buses heads there he goes
here's Johnny
my mom had this habit of like when they
would get into a heated fight she would
I know that I know this as an adult I
know why she would do this she would do
this to piss him off cuz he's like
talking to her right and they're going
out and they're yelling she goes I don't
want to hear you talk and he goes well
you have to hear me talk so he goes in
she always goes into him and locks the
[__] door and so he can't come in and
this is the house that he owns right and
he you know as a man I feel like that's
a violation it's like yo I work hard I
work I should be able to enter this room
I was trying to talk to you she's just
saying berating him just dissing him
through the [__] doors like you know
you hear not [__] in Korean right blah
blah blah you can't even visit that
[__] magnet I love hearing a good
tell off in Korean and I'm listening to
this [__] as a child and my deck is so
[__] mad he literally starts kicking
the door [__] down and so my dad
[__] up this door and opens it up right
and then my mom looks at him and has the
audacity and she goes I guess you just
like breaking your own property now
don't you and I'm like
she wasn't the catalyst for this to
happen they were tired you know and I'm
looking and my dad is now even more
pissed right she goes well who has to
pay for this and I'm sitting there and
then she does the one other thing I can
remember this like it was yesterday she
goes she goes guess what I'm fed up with
you I'm taking the kids all back to cran
you'll never see them again
and I'm like why you got to say this mom
why you always she always takes it from
here to here late like this woman would
like sleep on bus stops just to make
sure that he knows that he has something
to worry about
you haven't sure that you haven't heard
that story of the podcast but you okay
so you know she sleeps on a pot she
sleeps on a [__] bench and mind you
this this store is like 15 miles away
and she's walking on a tiny ass little
Korean feet in the part of South
Sacramento sleeping on a bench with one
spotlight on her I've never heard
Sacramento sound so hard as the east
side of Sarita yes that was a little
rough right yeah so it's a little rough
that's the area that I kind of grew up
in and so she's walking her tiniest
little Asian self I just walking by
without a care in the [__] where I
seen her do that [__] by the way during
a torrential downpour I'm talking about
rain coming down on her let me say
something hell hath no fury like a war
I had like as a wife I had to really die
unto myself to get rid of that because
there would be a point where I'm not
proud of this but like I pledged my
husband in the face in the middle of a
vine like caught off on him for stuff I
was even mad at him I was mad at one of
our former mutual friends right and he
like kind of took up for him so we went
to eat out of attitude then he was like
what's wrong with you
possibly alcohol was involved as well
like I broke my sandal trying to get to
him like fell over a basket but I was
like oh no you don't fit like punched
him in the face and all he could do was
just like try and restrain me hmm thank
you honey for not breaking up with me
but like it was to the point where and I
don't know if it's maybe we feel like
our voices aren't heard and like you're
gonna listen to me but there would be no
there was no end there used to be no end
to what I would do to make sure I was on
top so like I can relate to your mom
going to sleep on a bus stop like oh no
you're gonna worry about me
even if I'm put into myself in danger
and I end up in human sex trafficking
it's your fault because you drove me to
this right and I had to like thank God
for premarital counseling it all that
other stuff because I had to learn like
that's not okay this isn't your enemy it
took you premarital counseling that was
you know it really people you wanna know
why is because the premarital counseling
was like all right he's our pastor today
my best friend's dad he's like a father
figure to us he said do you want to be
right or do you want to be married
that's facts and it is facts because
it's like dang I used to do anything to
like crew I mean the point to where I am
now Megan at making at 34 I'm not 35 yet
almost at 35 making at 30 more it's very
different from Megan at 24 cuz Megan at
24 not only did it
I still don't take crap but I would not
take crap with my fists like if you
disrespected me you weren't gonna you
you were going to fill the replica like
if I said I will reach my whole fist
down your throat and snatch all your
vocal cords I would do that right but
that's not okay like I had to learn that
is not that is not okay that's not
effective that's not a proper way to
conduct myself so a lot of times people
who have known me for a little I mean
Khalifa tell you like for him I had to
take the stance like I don't care who
you are I will like mess with him I will
like it will be over like I don't like
wheat I'm not gonna go to all the story
but like different it ruin a friendship
because I was like if you make me choose
between you and him
I will not only choose him I will beat
you down in the
but now my stance is I can't choose him
and walk away from you without having to
resort to till that so like that
violence or whatever right but I think
it's also the point of feeling unheard
or feeling unseen and having to demit
like I now know I don't have to demand I
don't have to do antics to demand
respect if you're not just going to give
me respect for communicating this to you
then I'll block you like it's fine
see that's something that I've learned
because a lot of the stuff that my
parents do I I did right and not realize
until I was in a relationship so you
know let me tell you something just to
put it on the special mile crazy my mom
is like I was looking for a one time and
we finally found her this woman slept in
our zucchini patch in the backyard right
and you want to talk about this woman
came out with so many bug bites it
looked like not to say like like she
came out with so many bug bites right
she looks like King bats was trying to
do in Braille so much she was killed
monger she said all these what came bats
tried to do in brown why are you like
this
Davis like mom is really obsessed she
said dad she would do stuff to get a
reaction it's like it's almost like she
slept in that zucchini bash to let my
dad know these bug bites are because of
you you know what I mean yeah but that
but the thing is how did your mom grow
what you know they I don't I don't even
know actually but Broca's [__] for sure
cuz you open yeah but the thing is is
that like if your mom say your mom grew
up Brooke right she grew up broke broke
this I don't have to be broke to
understand that probably adds a whole
other level of stress to everything else
right I would hear stories about this
woman beating up other boys in school
because my mom actually has this thing
where she kiss
she doesn't have like sweat glands like
they don't work so for her what she has
to cope disease she has to use like ice
packs this year right oh it's not a
disease your mom can like die so she
can't be out in the Sun like got it so
um these boys used to make fun of her
these to call her like tomato face cuz
she would get really red so my mom being
this the crazy [__] woman that she
told me the story recently she was like
okay you know my mom whatever at the
time was probably a really cute girl I
don't really know but she would be like
yeah right and she was like okay well
let's meet up at the school ball blush
you start flirting with him a little bit
right so she flirted with in the meet
with them up after school
tell [__] then you told me she beat down
three boys with her mom is a queen who
needs to be protected what [__] woman
goes I can look at three other boys in
the stage and I'm gonna [__] you up
after school for calling me tomato face
tomato face your mom was truly like
she's the Korean black widow was like
best wifey material when we went back to
Korea when I was a kid I remember one of
her friends that she met up when I was
like eight years old but this was the
funniest thing that I could remember she
goes we're in Korea and my brother and
Mayer next to her and then she's said
well we're gonna meet one of my old
friends
and she goes oh it's been so long blah
blah blah in Korean she'll swear these
there's like these are my kids she goes
you got married
that's how unlikable of a human being my
mom was I don't think I like about this
problem that they're like who did you
meet that liar and my dad is somebody
who fights fire with fire too so he
doesn't take a lot of [__] so like
watching them fight constantly was very
entertaining as a child like throwing
rice cookers at each other that rice her
story still to this day yo my mom I
remember once my mom was so frustrated
it's funny that you bring up the fact
that she felt like she wasn't being
heard I want some hot mom sit on the
floor take a foldable chair you know
like WWE
those changes right she sat in my dad
slow room exactly so she felt like he
wasn't listening
she took the chair she started banging
it on her [__] head on the floor and
I looked at I was like what are you
doing she's like he won't listen and my
dad looks at me he goes I gotta find you
a new mommy always your dad go to [__]
it was like I'm gonna find you a new
mommy as a [__] 31 year old man
you're telling me you're gonna find me a
new mommy shut the [__] up old guy I'm
going cuz I because like my dad because
I have it and then I wanted to show her
how she was behaving and I'm like is
this how you want it look I was like is
this you she goes mommy crazy very
self-aware she's like yeah yeah you know
we all know I'm but she cooks well as
she loves a lot and the funny thing is
she's so smart like he's wise like her
advice is very [__] best but I don't
understand why she can't apply it to
herself
she's very good at giving me the best
words of wisdom but she always the
situation's have you ever talked to that
therapist
oh yeah go back to their home their
[__] life is a mess that's straight
mess or a teacher is like there's a room
with teachers that teachers children's
are actually the worst students to have
oh really
the worst and I say that because my mom
my mom cursed me right she's a teacher
she actually taught fifth grade in ABC
so like this is just if you would have
told me and if you would have told me at
21 I would be a teacher and love it like
I probably would have cut you out so I'm
like why would you wish that upon me
like the one thing I never wanted to
ever do in my life was be a teacher rule
is I'm what I tell you every single my
very first job I ever had was working in
the daycare in college I had I worked at
limited too which is now Justice which
is the children's clothing store
I entered at BT right but then I also
worked at an after-school nonprofit
organization so like I've known that
this was coming for a long time because
either I was going to be a pedophile or
I was gonna be a teacher it was one of
the two right I'm not a pedophile I'm
but my mom like my mom is was just like
the queen of of teaching which is
probably which is different being back
in her same district having so many
people that work with her know about her
which is why is it's a good thing that
I'm married because I'm Mitchell and not
keen cuz if I when I was ki they're like
oh my gosh do you happen to be related
to Pat King mine yeah I know that girl
but my mom was determined determined
that my sister and I because we both
attended the elementary school where she
taught that nobody could ever say that
we had favoritism right so the point in
fifth grade in fifth grade I was playing
tetherball because I was terrible
champion and I broke down Oprah and
Whitney together but I broke my thumb
all the way down to my wrist right like
it was just hanging oh [__]
hanging fifth grade lunch recess right
so a teacher mr. O'Mara may he rest in
peace
carries me farm I'm dramatic so he cares
we fire mister I'm like laid out for
your thumb I'm laid out it was my wrist
oh what's that got to do with your legs
it was painful it was painful
you let your face to tell you to redeem
myself for that during labor
I literally screamed not once
I cried not once
I cuss not once hi ib and i pushed a
9-pound baby out of this vagina
nine pounds ask my ask my husband
you could ask Britney you get I had I
had I did nothing so yeah so in fifth
grade Carrie fireman style because I
broke my wrist of my thumb I made up for
it for and given birth but he carries me
he takes you to her classroom and it's
lunchtime so he puts me on the table I'm
like I remember this so clear whoa she's
like does she have an asthma attacks
just like no something seems to be wrong
wrong with her wrist and thumb I was
like you didn't take her to the nurse's
office it's like have them take her to
the nurse's office have the front office
either call her grandparents which were
my mom's parents or call uncle Ron which
was my mom's best friend who happened to
be a teacher there her husband who they
lived around the corner if not she's
gonna have to stay in the office till
after school because I have to teach so
I did I laid up in the nurse's office
until 2:00 10:00 when school was
dismissed my mom graded her papers do
whatever she had to do took me to Kaiser
and bellflowers when Kaiser Bellflower
was in the hospital and we waited and I
left with a cast and she felt no remorse
she was like I was at work right I get
it because my own son attended the
school where I taught so he comes up he
goes thought to be on the playground and
he's like mrs. Mitchell because I'm not
mom or mom West one mrs. Mitchell he's
like I don't know he said mrs. Mitchell
he was like I left my poster at home and
I said well young man it looks like
you're gonna need to call one of your
parents you're gonna have to go to the
front office and like call them and see
if they can contact somebody on your
emergency car list because I'm at work
and when I'm at work I'm not a mom right
and so the students that were around
there like mrs. Mitchell you're not good
I was like I'm at work
he needs to go to the front
I mean he's left lunch and you know
somebody calls his teacher who I was you
know she has to be a friend but she was
like yeah you know Devin mentioned he
didn't have lunch I was like tell Devin
he's gonna have to talk to miss violet
and a specific if there's any money on
his account which I knew there was money
on his account but yeah we're like I'm
at work and I get it because nobody can
ever say at my school that sure dad
showed favoritism right but I did that
because I know I know and have
experienced other teachers who have had
their students work at the same or at
the same campus and they don't do that
same thing they'll eat lunch with the
kids the kids get feel like they rule
the school or whatever you're never
gonna say that about my kids but I also
feel like you have to do that as a black
parent as a black teacher who's a black
parent as well because is going to be
looked at three times is worse right
yeah because not only are you privileged
but then you're in then it will be like
oh they're indignant oh they're
disrespectful right whereas someone else
who's not black their kids could do the
same thing it was just be annoying or a
nuisance but it won't be looked at the
same I thought you were gonna tie his
shoes and like get to running go ahead
yeah no I like I remember like I was
very I knew how to deal with Devin going
to my school because of how my mom dealt
with my sister and I like if my mom good
no she she did like she was not playing
those games like we don't even leave
homework in the car like you if you left
homework at the car's not here
yeah like nobody was calling her I had
an asthma attack at school they had to
call the people in my emergency car
because my mom was like I'm at work I
can't like if I didn't teach at the
school I couldn't come to your rescue
right
and so it's this thing it's the same
thing for for Devin and it will be with
McKenith McKenna goes in my school
there's one be like hey you don't have a
mom when you're here you're at school
I'm just another teacher don't in the
office my office secretary
would they would like I can't believe
mrs. Smith show that you're making Devon
do I'm like I am mrs. Mitchell I'm not
his mom here I had to service 32 other
students that are in fifth grade he's
not a fifth grader at least he didn't
like I had to look I had to listen to my
mom give the fifth grade girl talk in
front of all the other students with all
the girls looking at me like your mom's
talking to us about periods at least
didn't have to go through that that's
true that's the mom of the Year award
well guys that wraps up this period
minstrel cycle well that wraps up the
pocket well guys that wraps up this
episode of the podcast if you guys have
questions below I know that we got
really deep into a very specific topic
that sometimes makes people feel
uncomfortable but if you have questions
discuss it in the comments below and
yeah man see what you guys can do dig
deep inside and ask yourself why I even
I've been doing it a lot I've been
finding out a lot of new stuff about
myself like watching Elijah I'm
wondering why for a whole [__] week I
couldn't stop crying I'm like why does
this hurt me so much I had to sit there
and I have to think about the stuff too
it's not like oh because you grew up
around a black community you know
everything I don't know [__] you know
even if you're black you don't know [__]
exactly so this is a learning experience
and I think is a human experience for
all of us and yeah just dig deep find
out stuff about yourself and if you
don't want to do that you don't I'm
probably gonna make a video about you
real soon we'll see y'all next time